ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GET
STARTED AS A SUB COMMITTEE. AND
GIVEN THAT WE'VE GOT ABOUT THREE
PAGES OF- HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND RULES ALL I'LL
GET STARTED THERE AND THEN-
HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE SOME OTHER
MEMBERS SHOW UP BUT WE DO HAVE
THE VICE CHAIR AND- FORMER CHAIR
HERE WITH US SO WE GET STARTED
AS SUBCOMMITTEE. A GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE WELCOME. TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
UTILITIES AND ENERGY HEARING. WE
WILL ALLOW THE SERGEANTS CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO THE AGENDA WE HAVE
FEW HOUSEKEEPING COMMENTS TO
MAKE. TODAY WE HAVE EIGHT BILLS
ON THE AGENDA PLEASE NOTE THAT
A. B. TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR.
COOLEY WAS PULLED FROM THE FILE
- WE DO HAVE TO. MAKE THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT WE WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE ROOM OR REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE WILL HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ROBERT RIVAS
ISAAC BRIAN AND JOSE MEDINA
TEMPORARILY FILLING THE ABSENCES
IN OUR COMMITTEE TODAY SO WE
WELCOME THEM. UPON THEIR
ARRIVAL. FINALLY WE HAVE LIFTED
OUR MASK MANDATE. BUT ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IS ENCOURAGED TO
WEAR A MASK WHILE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. WE HAVE A FEW OPTIONS
FOR WITNESSES TO TESTIFY TODAY.
TODAY IN THE HEARING ROOM IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN THE
BILL PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I ASKED THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE. THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. 877-692-8957 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE. ONE
NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT OKAY WE'VE
GOT A NEW PHONE NUMBER HERE. IS. 888-272-8451 M. AGO. THE
ACCESS CODE WILL REMAIN THE SAME
MIGHT I THINK THAT AND THAT IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN I'LL REPEAT THAT ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
WEBSITE OF THE UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING THEIR
BILL PRESENTATION. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A
MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY
OR AGAINST THE BILL. YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE AND WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED. ON TO SPEAK. YOU
HAVE ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATE PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMEDIAN NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO EIGHT
THREE. AND OUR TEAM WILL BE
THERE TO HELP. WE'RE ALSO
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY.
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. TODAY WE HAVE A
MEASURES ON THE AGENDA THREE ARE
ON THE CONSENT. HAS PROCEED WITH
THE WITNESSES AND PUBLIC COMMENT
I WANT TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE ASSEMBLY.
HAS RULES TO ENSURE WE MAINTAIN
ORDER AND RUN AN EFFICIENT AND
FAIR HEARING. TESTIMONIES THE
MINUTES TO FOUR MINUTES TOTAL
TWO MINUTES TO SUPPORT TWO
MINUTES. TO OPPOSE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ON A
MEASURE. ONLY STATE YOUR NAME
POSITION AND AFFILIATION IF ANY
. WE WILL LIMIT THE REMOTE
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIODS OF THIS
HEARING WHERE WITNESSES ONLY
STATE THEIR NAME POSITION. AND
AFFILIATION TO TWENTY MINUTES
PER BILL. IF WE EXCEED THIS TIME
FOR THE MEASURE YOU ARE CALLING
IN FOR PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE EMAIL
ADDRESS ON. OUR WEBSITE- WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET. AND I
DON'T SEE ANY- MEMBERS- TO
PRESENT ANY BILLS AT THE MOMENT. IS THAT WE HAVE A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. ALL RIGHT HOME. WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET- SALAS
TO SERGEANTS TO START MAKING
SOME PHONE CALLS
. EIGHT
SO WE'RE GOING TO. GET STARTED A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND AS CHAIR TAKE
THE PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT ON TWO
BILLS THAT ARE ON THE AGENDA
TODAY BEFORE WE DO THAT WE DO
WANT TO JUST REPEAT THE CALL IN
NUMBER- AND THE ACCESS CODE THE
CALL NUMBERS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
NUMBER IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN THE- VICE CHAIR
WILL NOW- RESUME WITH ME.
AND SIX WAS STATE HAS MADE SOME
TREMENDOUS STRIDES IN MEETING
OUR RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS
CLOSER WE GET TO THE TWENTY
FORTY FIVE DEADLINE THE MORE
DIFFICULT IT WILL BE TO REACH
THESE GOALS ONE OF THESE
DIFFICULTIES IS A NEED TO
BOLSTER AND EXPAND OUR ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING THE
BUILD OUT OF TRANSMISSION
FACILITIES THE PROCESS OF
CONSTRUCTING NEW TRANSMISSION
LINES IS BOTH TIMELY AND COSTLY.
THESE PROJECTS CAN TAKE UP TO A
DECADE A PERMIT AND BUILD AND
THE TOTAL PRICE TAG TO BUILD UP
IS NECESSARY AND ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD RESULT IN
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WHICH COULD
BE PASSED ON TO RATEPAYERS
CALIFORNIA IS FALLING BEHIND IN
PLANNING AND BUILDING THE
ELECTRIC TRANSMISSION.
FACILITIES NEEDED TO MEET OUR
CLEAN ENERGY AND CLIMATE TARGETS
THIS BILL WOULD LEAD TO
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING MECHANISMS
WHILE ALIGNING THE TRANSMISSION
PLANNING PROCESS WITH OUR GHG
REDUCTION GOALS WHILE ENSURING
CALAIS SOULS COMPETITIVE
SOLICITATION PROCESS IS
UNAFFECTED I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
WITH ME TODAY BE DON WHITE THEME
PARK CAMPAIGN IN JAZZ MONEY
JONES. INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS. THANK YOU. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF JOHN WHITE
WITH THE CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN IS
VERY NICE TO BE BACK WITH YOU IN
PERSON I'VE I'VE I'VE ENJOYED
THE PROCESS TO TESTIFYING SO.
I'M GLAD TO BE HERE. THIS IS A
BILL THAT WE CAME UPON- AFTER
LOOKING OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS AT WHY THINGS HAVE GOTTEN
BOGGED DOWN IN- WHERE THERE
MIGHT BE OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE
SOME IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE FOUND
A COUPLE OF PROVISIONS- ONE IS
THE EXISTING LAWPROVIDES A- A
PRESUMPTION OF NEEDS FOR
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS. THAT ARE
NEEDED TO MEET THE R. P. S.
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD.
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY EXPAND
THAT PRESUMPTION OF NEED TO
INCLUDE. TRANSMISSION PROJECTS
NEEDED OF TO ACHIEVE SB ONE
HUNDRED. THE SECOND PART OF THE
BILL IS A IS A STUDY BILL OUR
STUDY PROVISION BY THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK AND PC. TO
LOOK AT ALTERNATIVE WAYS OF
BUILDING AND FINANCING.
TRANSMISSION IT DOESN'T SPECIFY
A PREFERRED PREFERENCE- COULD BE
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS COULD BE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH FEDERAL
AGENCIES BUT THE IDEA IS TO SEE
IF WE CAN FIND WAYS OF REDUCING
THE COST THE TRANSMISSION- SO
THAT WE CAN. BUILD OUT THE
NEEDED RESOURCES- WITH WITH LESS
IMPACT ON RATES WE ASK FOR YOUR
I. PHONE. THANK VERY MUCH- CHAIR
AND- THAT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHANCE MONEY JONES
FROM THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS. AND THAT WE REPRESENT
A BROAD PORTFOLIO RESOURCES-
INCLUDING- UTILITY SCALE
RENEWABLES US NATURAL GAS LONG
DURATION STORAGE STORAGE AND
INDEPENDENT TRANSMISSION
DEVELOPERS. WE'RE SUPPORTING AB-
TWENTY SIX NINETY SIX BECAUSE WE
THINK THAT THE- ISSUE WITH
RESPECT TO A ONCE THE ISO'S GONE
THROUGH A VERY THOROUGH ANALYSIS
OF NEED- THAT THERE REALLY IS NO
REASON TO DO A NEEDS ANALYSIS
AGAIN THIS WILL SAVE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME. TRANSMISSION AS
I THINK THE AUTHOR HAS INDICATED
TAKES A GOOD- SIGNIFICAN MY
TIMES ARE DOING A NEED ANALYSIS
TWICE ON THE SAME PROJECT MAKES
NO SENSE. THERE IS SOME ARCANE
LANGUAGE WITH RESPECT TO WHAT
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS ARE OR
NOT THAT WILL HAVE TO SORT OUT
DOWN THE ROAD BUT NOT FOR TODAY-
BUT WE'RE WHICH SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND WE WOULD URGE AN AYE
VOTE. WE HAVE A. I WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ARE THERE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I DON'T
SEE ANY. GO TO THE PHONES. READY
GO TO THE PHONES FOR A- THOSE
WHO WANT TO TESTIFY AND IN IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. I'M AS MODERATOR WOULD
YOU- CHECK THE LINES PLEASE.
THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE
YOUR POSITION ON THIS BILL
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO PLEASE. FOUR
ONE TWO PHONES YOU HAVE A FEW
LINES IN Q. WILL BE JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE.
OUR FIRST COMMUNIST NINE THREE
OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MELISSA CORTEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. WE HAVE LINE TO EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
A KENNEDY WITH OPTIONAL POWER
AND SAN FRANCISCO AND I JUST
WANT TO GET SOME CLARITY THIS IS
IN REFERENCE TO AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY THREE. HELLO OKAY I WILL
BE- WAIT I WAS ASKED TO CALL
INTERNET FOR CAL STORES OKAY
I'LL DECLINE AT THIS TIME SINCE
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE BILL
TO BE DISCUSSED SORRY. THANK YOU
NUMBER FOUR NINE THREE FIFTEEN
I'M SORRY WE'RE ON THE ITEM- TWO
FIVE EIGHT SEVEN. OKAY
NONSTARTERS I'M SORRY TWO SIX
NINE SIX I'M THIRTY SIX NINE SIX
SORRY. ALL WORKS ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA IN THE LARGE SCALE SOLAR
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. YOU
HAVE ONE MORE COMMON IN Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANK TO NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SANTIAGO
WITH CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS CALLING IN SUPPORT.
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU ON THE
PHONE LINES.
AT ON THE PHONES. I MISS CHAIR
WE WANT TO- ESTABLISH A QUORUM
AND THEN YOU CAN CONCLUDE. CHECK
ALL RIGHT LET'S LET'S CALL FOR
THE QUORUM. EDUARDO GARCIA
PRESIDENT PATTERSON. BRIAN
CARILLO. CHEN CUNNINGHAM.
CRISTINA GARCIA HOLDEN MAYES
MURDER TUESDAY- MEDINA HERE
REYES. SANTIAGO THANK RIVAS.
QUORUM IS PRESENT JERRY WANNA
CLOSE I THANK YOU FOR- YOUR
ATTENTION ON THE MATTER
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. AB
MEMBERS YOU HAVE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MMHM. I-
WANT TO REMIND MISTER SPENDING
JONES AT- AT A RECENT CONFERENCE
I WAS JUST ASKING YOU ABOUT HOW
WE CAN. TRY TO SPEED UP THE- THE
BUILDING OF THE TRANSMISSION.
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER TO
ACCOMMODATE OUR- OUR- HOPEFULLY.
COMING ONLINE SOON- OFFSHORE
WIND AND OTHER CLEAN ENERGY-
GENERATION AND SO- IN THE THIS
BILL- IT IS VERY TIMELY- BUT-
OTHER THAN DECLARING THAT- ANY
NEW TRANSMISSION TO BE NECESSARY
TO MEET. OUR SB ONE HUNDRED
GOALS. HOW IS THIS GOING TO
ACTUALLY SPEED UP- THE BUILDING
OF THE TRANSMISSION GRID. YEAH
WHAT WHAT IT DOES IS IT
BASICALLY IT'S YOU IT'S
UTILIZING THE AYE ESOS- NEED
ANALYSIS THAT CAME OUT OF THIS
THE SELECTION PROCESS THAT WHICH
IS VERY THOROUGH SO THERE'S
ISSUES REGARDING IS IT NEEDED
FOR POLICY REASONS THAT'S WHERE%
WOULD COME UP. THE P. YOU SEE
WOULD NOT HAVE TO RE LITIGATE
THOSE ISSUES UP IN OTHER WORDS
THAT SAVES A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF TIME BECAUSE I'M ASSUMING
THAT IF PEOPLE HAVE OBJECTIONS
OR DON'T THINK THAT THE POLICIES
RIGHT WITH THE AND THERE'S- A
FORM AVAILABLE TO RAISE THOSE
ISSUES BUT AGAIN THESE HAVE
TENDED TO BE A HIGHLY TECHNICAL
OF THE DETAIL IN THE DIVIDEND
AGAIN- PART OF THAT PROCESS IS
IT'S COMPETITIVE AS WELL SO IF
THAT LINE IT REALLY ISN'T
NEEDED. THAT COULD BE DISPLACED
BY SOMETHING ELSE THAT GENERALLY
HAPPENS THAT PROCESS SO WHAT IT
IS TAKING ONE EXTRA STEP OF THAT
PROCESS TO. BUT IT'S NOT AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS INDICATES-
INTENDED TO REPLACE THE
COMPETITIVE BIDDING PROCESS NO
OKAY THAT'S NOT THE INTENT IT.
OKAY- AND CURRENTLY I THINK WE
ARE WE ALSO HEARD FROM THE PC
THAT IT TAKES ON AVERAGE ABOUT
TEN YEARS TO- BILL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS WOULD
CORRECTIVE WE'RE TRYING TO
TRUNCATE THAT PRETTY
SIGNIFICANTLY AND I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
IF WE'RE GOING TO MEET THE GOALS
THAT WE HAVE NOT ONLY FOR
PURPOSES OF YOU KNOW CLEANING UP
THE YOU KNOW GETTING TO A TO A
GREENER APPROVED CARBON NEUTRAL-
WE ALSO HAVE RELIABILITY
AFFORDABILITY AND A LOT OF
THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
TRANSMISSION SO WE NEED TO. BE
ABLE TO MOVE THAT PROCESS ALONG
A LITTLE QUICKER AND OUR HOPE
HERE- IS THIS IS MAY BE ONE STEP
OUT OF SEVERAL THAT MAY BE
NECESSARY TO COULD HELP MOVE
THAT ALONG. OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH. RIGHT THANK A GOOD
QUESTIONS I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
BE HAVING AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. THAT FOCUSES- TYPICALLY
ON THE TIME FRAME OF-
TRANSMISSION SITING BUILDING AND
THEN OF COURSE COST THE ISSUE OF
AFFORDABILITY RIGHTS ARE
EXPECTED AS RIVAL PROVIDES CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK ANY OTHER MEMBERS. WE HAVE
A MOTION. BUDGET WELL MOTION AND
A SECOND TO PASS AS AMENDED. TO
NATURAL RESOURCES THE CONVO
EDUARDO GARCIA HI I EDUARDO
GARCIA GARCIA AYE PATTERSON HI
PATTERSON HI BRIAN. BRIAN I
CARILLO CORREO AYE CHAN CHEN NOT
VOTING CUNNINGHAM. CRISTINA
GARCIA. HOLDEN HARPER HOLDEN I.
MAYES MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI AYE
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE REYES
REYES I SANTIAGO. THANK RIVAS
RIVAS I. NINE ZERO. IT'S PASSES
HIS NIGHT IS THERE IT'S OUT
THANK YOU SOARED UP THE NEXT
BILL YES SIR A. B. R. TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN ACCELERATES
THE DEVELOPMENT AND EXPANSION OF
FROM RESOURCES WHICH ARE KNOWN
TO PROVIDE RELIABILITY DIVERSITY
AND RESIDENCY TO ARTICLE GREAT
WHILE HELPING CALIFORNIA MEET
ITS CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS. THIS
BILL WILL SUPPORT WHAT WE ARE
AFRAID TO FASTER GROWTH THE FIRM
RESOURCES THAT OFFER PROMISE OF
A BY MEDICAL BENEFITS AND GOOD
PAYING JOBS TO SOME CALIFORNIANS
IN RURAL AREAS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES SPECTROSCOPY I WROTE
JASMINE JONES AS WELL AS- MISTER
JOHN I WANT CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN
WE SUPPORT THE BILL WE NEED A
BALANCED PORTFOLIO WE NEED TO
HAVE OF DIVERSITY OF RESOURCES
AND THE FIRM CLEAN RESOURCES ARE
NEED TO BE IMPORTANT FOR. THAT
PURPOSE. YES BUT HE JONES FROM
NATIVE ENERGY PRODUCERS AND AS I
GAVE YOU TO LET OF EVERYBODY
THAT I REPRESENT- YEAH- WHICH IS
A- NOAH'S ARK OF THE GENERATORS-
MY- BUT I DO REPRESENT FIRM-
RENEWABLES- SPECIFICALLY
GEOTHERMAL AND BIOMASS SEVERAL
OTHERS. ISN'T THIS IS IMPORTANT
IS ELECTRIC SECTORS ALWAYS BUILT
SORT OF ON STEPS OF- RESOURCES
IN TERMS OF HOW THEY RUN AND
IT'S BECOME EVEN INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT AS WE SHIP TO- DOES
SOME SOME OTHER TECHNOLOGIES SO.
WE HAVE LOSING BASELOAD
RESOURCES INTO WEST CALIFORNIA
OBVIOUSLY SONG SHUT DOWN EARLIER
IN THE LAST DECADE DIABLO CANYON
- THE COMMUTER GOING N GOING
DOWN ABOUT EIGHTEEN MONTHS UNIT
TO ABOUT A YEAR DID YOU TWO AND
A HALF YEARS FROM NOW- THOSE ARE
ALL RESOURCES THAT ARE OPERATING
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN KEEPING THE
LIGHTS ON- WHATEVER YUR
POSITION IS A NUCLEAR POWER
DOESN'T REALLY MATTER. THAT'S
WHAT THEY DID AND SO NOW HOW ARE
WE GONNA REPLACE THAT- NOT INK
IN CALIFORNIA IN ADDITION TO
THAT YOU'VE GOT OTHER BASELOAD
RESOURCES THAT ARE RETIRING
THROUGHOUT THE WEST. AND SO THAT
WOULD THAT WE BELIEVE THAT IS
THAT THIS WILL. BE A PROVIDE- IT
IF THIS WERE THE- IN THE- UCW.
FORWARD LITTLE MORE AGGRESSIVELY
WITH RESPECT TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE FIRM- RESOURCES INTO AN
ENERGY MIX. THANK YOU. YEAH WE
HAVE A MOTION BY- HOLDEN A
SECOND BY A CARILLO. I DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION. ALL THESE
ARE STRONG SUPPORT SORRY ABOUT
THAT. PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHERE IN
SUPPORT. SCOTT WHAT SHOULD BE AT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PATRIOTS
COUNCIL THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYERS
IN THE WESTERN STATES CONSERVE
SHEET METAL WORKERS. IN SUPPORT
. ARE ANY UP PEOPLE IN THE ROOM
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE. RIGHT
SEEING AND HEARING NUMBER. WHEN
I GO TO THE PHONES. MISTER
MODERATOR. SO YOUR POSITION ON
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
BORNEMANN ZERO. FIRST WE HAVE
LINE TO NINETY. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JULIA LEVIN WITH THE
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ADDITIONAL LINES
COMING TO THE PHONE ONE MOMENT.
LINE THREE TWENTY ONE. YEAH YEAH. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE STATE
YOUR POSITION IN WHICH BOTH
SIDES. YES BUT I'M REALLY AREN'T
ON THE PREVAILING WAGE BILL FOR
OCTOBER OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND. I
THINK YOU ARE THAT WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT TAKING THAT BILL UP
THIS THAT'S A DIFFERENT BILL
WILL GET TO THAT A BIT. THIS IS
A B. TWO FIVE EIGHT SEVEN
CORRECT. RIGHT BORDERLINE THREE
TWENTY THREE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THAT THE LACK OF BE
OCCURRING CALLING IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ENERGY
STORAGE ALLIANCE THANK YOU. NO
OTHER LINES IN Q. RIGHT NOW I'M
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
AND RIGHT CLOSE THANK YOU ARE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. YOUR CALL QUESTION OKAY. RIGHT NOW THIS DO PASSED AS
AMENDED O NATURAL RESOURCES
CORRECT RIGHT. EDUARDO GARCIA I
EDUARDO GARCIA I PATTERSON
PATTERSON I BRIAN. BRIAN I
CARILLO CARILLO AYE CHAN CHAN I
CUNNINGHAM. CRISTINA GARCIA
HOLDEN HOLDEN I. MAYES OUR CITY
MURATSUCHI AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
REYES REYES AYE SANTIAGO. TANG
RIVAS HI. ZERO CAN ZERO THAT THE
BILL WAS OUT.
SO WE'LL LOCK NOW- ASSET THE
CONSENT CALENDAR BE VOTED ON. DO
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A
MOTION IT'S REYES SECOND THAT
WAS ROLLED IN. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE THREE ITEMS.
IT'S A BE SIXTEEN SEVENTY SIX
WAS GRAYSON ITEM THREE A. B.
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT.
DONALD ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE
FROM THE CUNNINGHAM BEFORE WE
CALL THE QUESTION HERE I BELIEVE
ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES WANTED. TO
MAKE SOME COMMENTS ON ONE OF THE
ITEMS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF A FOR THE COURTESY I- WANTED
TO- I. REQUEST AND THAT- I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE SEEN FROM VOTING ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AS TO THE-
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY SIX GRAYSON AND- ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT CUNNINGHAM- WHILE
I DON'T SEE. ISSUES WITH THE
BILL STANDING ALONE THIS THIS IS
A PART OF WHAT I EXPECT TO BE A
VERY CONTENTIOUS DEBATE THIS
YEAR. ON CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES. I EXPECT.
THERE TO BE A ROBUST DEBATE AND
- SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES-
WHERE THIS WE'RE BOTH OF THE
BILLS WILL BE GOING FORWARD AND
SO- I WOULD JUST. REQUEST THAT
THIS COMMITTEE TO TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION GOING FORWARD
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT THERE'S
GONNA BE A SLEW OF CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE BILLS THIS
YEAR- GOING FORWARD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LET THE RECORD
REFLECT THIS RUMOR SAID SHE WILL
BE STANDING FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WITH THAT BAND
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THEN FIVE. IN ORDER GARCIA
HI EDUARDO GARCIA HI PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BRIAN BRIAN I
CARILLO CARILLO AYE CHAN. CHEN
AYE CUNNINGHAM CRISTINA GARCIA
HOLDEN HOLDEN I. MAYES
MURATSUCHI NOT BUT MURATSUCHI
NOT VOTING MEDINA MEDINA AYE
REYES. YES I SANTIAGO TING RIVAS
RIVAS I. NINE ZERO THANK YOU
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE MEMBERS
TO ADD ON MOVING ON TO A REGULAR
AGENDA WE CAN BEGIN- BUT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY AUTHORS- ALMOST
WAS GRILLED YOU LIKE TO TAKE
YOUR BILL GIVEN. THAT WE DON'T
HAVE OTHER OFFICE HERE. SURE.
ALL RIGHT WELCOME TO AND- I
DON'T FOR A BI TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE DOES HAVE A TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO- OUR NEIGHBORS BY MID
RECOMMENDATION. FORGERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT SOMEONE
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE I KNOW THIS IS A SUCH
AN IMPORTANT TOPIC THAT WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING FOR QUITE A FEW
YEARS NOW AND I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
FORTY THREE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
PREVAILING WAGE FOR SOLAR
PROJECTS OVER FIFTEEN KILOWATTS
THAT OPT INTO THE NET ENERGY
METERING PROGRAM AND WOULD
REQUIRE THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH AN ANNUAL
REPORT ON ROOFTOP SOLAR
ADOPTION. BY CENSUS TRACT IN
SUPPOSED THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IN KIT IS
CALIFORNIA'S LEAD ENTITY TO
REGULATE CALIFORNIA'S UTILITIES
AND ACT ON BEHALF OF REPAIRS ON
THE PUBLIC AT LARGE AND THEY'VE
USE THAT MANDATE TO CREATE
GENEROUS INCENTIVES FOR ROOFTOP
SOLAR IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAS LED
THE NATION WE ARE ALL INCREDIBLY
PROUD OF THOSE EFFORTS WHEN
STATE AUTHORITY IS BEING USED TO
CREATE AN INCENTIVE THE BENEFIT
SOME OF THE COST OF OTHERS
HOWEVER IT'S INCUMBENT UPON THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE A CLOSE LOOK
AND MAKE SURE THAT IT PUBLIC
BENEFIT IS BEING DERIVED.
MEMBERS LET ME BE VERY CLEAR
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT MAKING
CHANGES TO THE TERRACE OFFERED
BY NET ENERGY METERING PROGRAM
NOR DOES IT IMPACT SMALL SCALE
ROOFTOP SOLAR RATHER THIS BILL
DOES TWO THINGS THAT WILL HELP
ENSURE ALL CALIFORNIANS YOUR
RETURN ON AN INCENTIVE CREATED
ON THEIR BEHALF IT IS THE
REALITY THAT SOLAR INSTALLERS
ARE NOT PAID AS MUCH AS OTHER
ELECTRICAL WORKERS THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF EXAMPLES FROM THE LAST
DECADE OF LARGE COMPANIES THAT
HAVE USED INNOVATION AS AN
EXCUSE TO DRIVE DOWN WAGES FROM
RIDE SHARE TO WAREHOUSE WORK.
AND THIS IS ACTUALLY A REALITY
THAT WE CANNOT ACCEPT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO A CLEAN ENERGY
ECONOMY. CAN HAS BEEN A WORLD
LEADER AND CLEAN GREEN ENERGY
WOULD NOT ONLY INVESTMENTS BUT
ALSO IN THE PLANNING NECESSARY
TO GET TO ONE HUNDRED PERCENT.
RENEWABLES BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
THAT BILL IS ACTUALLY SB ONE
HUNDRED WHICH I CO AUTHORED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. MY FIRST YEAR
IN THE ASSEMBLY. TE LEGISLATURE
HAS AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO THE
WORK NECESSARY TO REDUCE OUR
STATE'S CONSUMPTION OF FOSSIL
FUELS. AND THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF CONVERSATION REGARDING THE
WORK FORCE IN THE FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY. AS THE STATE MOVES
AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS THE NEW
DRILLING OR FRACKING. INCENTIVES
TOWARDS RENEWABLE ENERGY MUST
INCLUDE A CLEAN GREEN ENERGY
WORK FORCE. THIS IS OFTEN
DISCUSSED AS A JUST TRANSITION
BUT WHAT DOES THAT REALLY MEAN
WHEN WE ACTUALLY THINK OF
WORKERS. THIS BILL WILL UNLOCK
WILL LOCK IN. A FAIR
COMPENSATION FOR SOLAR
INSTALLERS WORKING ON LARGE
PROJECTS THAT OPT INTO THE
PUBLIC PROVIDED INCENTIVES. THAT
NUMBER PROVIDES. THE OTHER
ACTION OF THIS BILL WILL TAKE ON
AN ADDRESS A NEED FOR GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND COMMUNITY
INCLUSION AROUND THE BENEFITS.
THAT THE NET ENERGY METERING
PROGRAM PROVIDES THIS IS ALL
THROUGH A LENS OF EQUITY. RIGHT
NOW THE LEGISLATURE DOES NOT
HAVE GOOD DATA ON ROOFTOP SOLAR.
UPTAKE IN NEIGHBORHOODS BY
NEIGHBORHOODS. WHAT WE DO KNOW
FROM UC BERKELEY STUDY AND THAT
FROM THE PUC'S OWN REPORT ON
AFFORDABILITY. IS THAT RATE
PAYERS AND UNDER REPRESENT
NINETIES ARE MUCH LESS LIKELY TO
BENEFIT FROM THEM. THAT THE
KASHIF MAKES THE RATE BURDEN
HIGHER WE ALSO KNOW THAT 2% OF
THE REBATES. OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR INCENTIVE UP I'M SORRY THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR INITIATIVE.
WENT TO AFFORDABLE AND MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING. HOW CAN WE
ADDRESS THE DISPARITIES. IF WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
NEIGHBORHOODS. THEY ARE IN OR
THAT THEY EXIST. AVAILABLE HERE
TO TESTIFY ON HOW THIS BILL WILL
BENEFIT WORKERS AND UNDER UNDER
UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES AT
SCOTT WHICH SITTING HERE RIGHT
IN FRONT OF ME. RIGHT NEXT TO
ME- WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE IS
A ATION OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS MR
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER SCOTT
WHICH ON BEHALF OF BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES AND THE STATE
ASSOCIATION ELECTRICAL WORKERS
I'D LIKE TO FIRST ADDRESS THE
EQUALITY ISSUE FOR THE COMMITTEE
. LAST YEAR THE UC BERKELEY HAAS
SCHOOL OF BUSINESS. PUT OUT A
STUDY THAT FOUND THAT BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES HAVE
EXPERIENCE FAR LESS SOLAR
INVESTMENT IN WHITE COMMUNITIES
EVEN WHEN ADJUSTED FOR INCOME.
THIS IS NOT SURPRISING TO THOSE
OF US WHO WATCH THESE PROGRAMS
FOR SOME TIME I COULD CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS HANNAH TODAY
HEADED OUT. YOU'LL SEE THE
SLIDES THAT THE- HOUSEHOLD OF
THREE MAKING A MERE FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PAID INTO THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR INITIATIVE.
THAT PROGRAMS SPENT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. ON SUBSIDIZING
. ROOFTOP SOLAR. 7% THAT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS WENT TO
AFFORDABLE OR LOW INCOME HOUSING
. THE REST OF IT WHICH
COMMERCIAL RETAIL AND MARKET
RATE HOUSING. I CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE NEXT SLIDE THIS
HAD THEY GAVE YOU THIS IS FOR
THE NET METERING PROGRAM TO
DATE. WE'VE DONE THE FIRST SLIDE
WE'VE DONE JUST ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS IN ROOFTOP
SOLAR UNDER THE NAME PROGRAM HOW
MUCH OF GOING TO PORTTO PORT
COMMUNITIES. LESS THAN ONE
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS HAVE GONE TO
SINGLE FAMILY AFFORDABLE SOLAR
HOMES MULTI FAMILY AFFORDABLE
SOLAR HOUSING OR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IT'S SHAMEFUL THIS
BILL IS A SMALL BUT IMPORTANT
STEP TOWARDS THAT. I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK TO THE SECOND PART OF THIS
BILL. JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CONTRACTORS
LICENSING BOARD COMMISSIONED A
STUDY BY THE UC BERKELEY LABOR
CENTER. THAT PROVIDED A AN
ARTICLE THAT THE QUOTES IT. THAT
STUDY FOUND THAT THE AVERAGE
SOLAR INSTALLER IN CALIFORNIA
MAKES A MERE TWENTY THREE
DOLLARS TOTAL PACKAGE. OKAY THE
STUDY ALSO FOUND. EVIDENCE SHOWS
THAT HIGHER WAGES DUE TO
PREVAILING WAGE DO NOT SLOW
SOLAR DEMAND WHY NOT INCLUDING
STATE THE FIRST LABOR COSTS
DON'T INCREASE MUCH WITH HIGHER
WAGES AND BENEFITS. INSTALLATION
LABOR REPRESENTS 6211% OF TOTAL
PROJECT COSTS SO EVEN LARGE
INCREASES IN WORKERS
COMPENSATION DON'T LEAD TO LARGE
INCREASE IN TOTAL COSTS IN OTHER
WORDS A 50% INCREASE IN LABOR
COSTS WOULD INCREASE TOTAL COSTS
BY ONLY THREE TO FIVE PERCENT.
THE STUDY FOUND THAT IF YOU
APPLIED PREVAILING WAGE THERE
WOULD BE AN INITIAL UPFRONT COST
INCREASE OF THREE TO FIVE
PERCENT. BUT SECOND FRONT THE
SECOND FINDING OF THE STUDY WAS
THAT THE IMPROVEMENTS IN WORKER
PRODUCTIVITY THAT COME WITH A
SKILLED WORK FIRST TYPICALLY
OFFSET THOSE WAGE INCREASES. AND
THE LAST LINE I'LL READ YOU SAYS
IF A SKILLED WORKER PROVIDES 50%
MORE VALUE OF YOUR PROJECTED BE
THAT UNSKILLED WORKER WHERE ONLY
ONLY 25% MORE PAY HIGHER
COMPENSATION IS A SOUND
INVESTMENT. THIS BILL ONLY
APPLIES. TWO ROOFTOP SOLAR
PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBSIDIZED THROUGH THE NAME
PROGRAM THERE ARE FIFTEEN.
KILOWATT HOURS ARE LARGER THAT
REPRESENTS ONLY 3% OF ALL THE
NAME INSTALLATIONS. MY FINAL
POINT YOU'RE PROBABLY WONDERING
HOW BIG IS A FIFTEEN KILOWATT
HOUR SOLAR ARRAY. SIXTY NINE
PANELS MAKING YOUR OWN HOME. FOR
YOUR HOME BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
SIXTY NINE PANELS THAT'S A BIG
PROJECT REAR DRIVERS. THANK YOU
WE'RE GOING TO ASK IF FOUGHT
THERE ARE OTHER. MEMBERS IN THE
AUDIENCE- SPEAKING IN FAVOR FEEL
STATE YOUR NAME. ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR POSITION PLEASE MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER. MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE WANTED TO SPEAK TO THE
- MATTERED SUPPORT CASEY NONE DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES-
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
COME FORWARD. TWO WITNESSES- YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES YOU GET TWO
MINUTES EACH. FOUR FIVE SIX WHAT
ARE WE GONNA MAYBE OR MAYBE LESS
GOVERNMENT MISTER WHICH IF
YOU'LL PLEASE- TWO WHAT SHOULD
WE HAVE ANOTHER CHAIR HOW TO
WILL GO WILL CALL IN BACK UP
WILL YOU BE CALLED BACK UP. GOOD
HELLO MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE CHAMBER- MY NAME IS KENNETH
WELLS I AM FROM COME TO
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS THE FORTY
FOURTH DISTRICT. I AND I AM A
SMALL CONTRACTOR LOGIN MY STORY
THAT I JUST WANT TO REPRESENT
HERE IS THAT I OWN AND OPERATE A
COMMERCIAL SOLAR ROOFTOP SOLAR
COMPANY IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- IN MOSTAR JUST CAME
FROM HUMBLE BEGINNINGS OF
STARTING A SOLAR WHERE THERE WAS
NO OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE FOR ME TO
WORK IN THE INDUSTRY FOR ABOUT
TWELVE YEARS. IN A TWELVE YEARS
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET TO WHERE I
AM NOW AND WHAT WE SPECIFICALLY
DO IS WORK ON A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WHERE WE WORK
DIRECTLY WITH PEOPLE FROM THESE
COMMUNITIES WHO OTHERWISE.
WOULDN'T HAVE OPPORTUNITY IN
THIS INDUSTRY TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE GETTING THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING THEY NEED
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS CLEAN TRIED
TO TRANSITION TO CLEAN ENERGY.
IF THIS BILL WAS THE PASS I
BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD DIRECTLY
KILL MY BUSINESS AS SOMEBODY WHO
NOT ONLY HAS THE ABILITY TO WORK
IN INDUSTRY BUT ALSO BE ENTRE
NOR AND OWN A SMALL BIZ I WOULD
NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO- MY
BUSINESS BECAUSE- IT WILL PUT
UNDUE BURDENS ON MY BUSINESS TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE TYPE OF.
COUNSEL IN THE TYPE OF PALM- I
GUESS YOU WOULD SAY- WAIT. TO MY
EMPLOYEES ARE THE KNEE UP. ALL
MY- IF I WAS TO BRING HIM HERE
SAY THEY ARE DIDN'T. WAY MORE
THEY WOULD ANOTHER OPPORTUNITIES
THAT COME FROM MY TYPE
NEIGHBORHOOD. AND I HOPE THAT WE
WILL TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WE- ALSO TAKING
SURVEYS ALL THE NUMBERS THAT ARE
ARE BE PRESENTED TO. PLEASE HI
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M COURTNEY
KORDA I AM A CO OWNER OF COURT A
SOLAR WE ARE AN EIGHT PERSON
SOLAR INSTALLER IN DANVILLE
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SIXTEEN ARE WE HAVE BEEN
INSTALLING SOLAR AND STORAGE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AS A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER I WEAR A
LOT OF HATS- LEGAL MARKETING H.
R. I DO A LOT OF THINGS MYSELF
AND ONE THING I WAS NOT ABLE TO
DO MYSELF IT WAS PREVAILING WAGE
I HELPED A FIRE DEPARTMENT GO
SOLAR IN MY CMMUNITY AND THE
RED TAPES TO DO THE SET UP IN
THE PROCESSING FOR THE
PREVAILING WAGE WAS SO TORTUROUS
AND COMPLICATED THAT I HAD TO
HIRE AN EXPENSIVE CONSULTANT
JUST TO HELP ME DO THAT. IT WAS
VERY BURDENSOME I DON'T KNOW HOW
ANY COMPETENT SMALL BUSINESS
PERSON COULD HANDLE THAT WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL STAFF JUST TO DO THE
PREVAILING WAGE PAPERWORK- THIS
IS A SECOND CAREER FOR ME I AM
DOING THIS BECAUSE I WANT TO
HELP THE STATE REACH ITS CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS I'M NOT DOING THIS
TO MAKE MILLIONS I PAY A
GENEROUS WAGE TO MY WORKERS WHO
WERE ON SKILLED BEFORE THEY CAME
TO ME I GIVE GOOD BENEFITS AND
MY WORKERS ARE HAPPY- I- I FEEL
THAT. I AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE IS A STEP IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION I THINK THERE'S SOME
FLAWED ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT HOW
PREVAILING WAGE WOULD ACT
BUSINESS LIKE KIND OF UNWIND I'M
IT WOULD MAKE SOLAR A LOT MORE
EXPENSIVE AND SLOW US DOWN JUST
AT A TIME WHEN OUR STATE NEEDS
TO TRIPLE AT LEAST THE SOLAR AND
STORAGE THAT WE HAVE INSTALLED
SMALL COMPANIES LIKE OURS ARE
IMPORTANT TO THAT AND WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO SLOW DOWN WE NEED TO
ACCELERATE WE DON'T NEED TO BE
DRIVING PEOPLE TOWARDS- FOSSIL
FUEL STICKING WITH GAS
GENERATORS WE NEED TO BE
INSTALLING MORE SOLAR AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY THREE WOULD PRICE US
OUT OF THE MARKET IT WOULD.
PRICE MY TYPICAL COMMERCIAL
CUSTOMERS OUT OF THE MARKET TO
THESE ARE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
DON'T HAVE PUBLIC WORKS BUDGETS
THEY'RE NOT ROADS AND BRIDGES AS
THEIR DENTAL. MY DENTIST MY A.
R. WELL I HELPED A HOMELESS
SERVICES CHARITY AND A APARTMENT
BUILDING IN A SMALL IN A LOW
INCOME AREA GO SOLAR I WOULD
LOSE THOSE TYPES OF CUSTOMERS IT
WOULD THREATEN MY BUSINESS I
WOULD GO OUT OF BUSINESS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE VOTE NO ON
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE THANK
YOU FOR TESTIFYING. WHEN ASKED
IF THERE ARE OTHER INDIVIDUALS
IN THE ROOM WHO ARE WISHING TO
SPEAK AND- NO POSITION TO THE
BILL. PLEASE COME FORWARD. OKAY
ONE OF THINGS THAT I SKIPPED.
EARLIER WAS OVER THE PHONE
LINES. AND ASK- THE MODERATOR TO
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES. AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE. TO TESTIFY
IN- IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION
ON THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO. HELLO FIRST
ONLINE TWO EIGHTY FOUR TO EIGHT
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND ABOUT FORTY
EIGHT I'M- I'M A MEMBER OF IBEW
AND I'M AT THE PORT OF A. B. TWO
ONE FOUR THREE AT THE LAST
MINUTE BILL WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT THEIR THE LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD FOR COMPETITIVE WAGES. FOR
THE WORKFORCE AS WE CONTINUE TO
TRANSITION TO CLEAN ENERGY.
WHILE ALSO ENSURING THAT THE
STATE COULD YOU THINK COLLECT
THE DATA NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
INEQUITIES BETWEEN HOMEOWNERS
RENTERS AND LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. I RECOMMEND THAT I
VOTE. THANK YOU. BACKSTRAP LINE
THREE OH THREE. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS EMILY LANGAN OND AND
I'M ONE OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR URBAN OF
ENERGY IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY
CALIFORNIA GOAL IS TO INCREASE
VOTER PRODUCTION AND LESSEN OUR
DEPENDENCE ON FOSSIL FUELS AND
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE WILL
TAKE THAT OPPORTUNITY AWAY FROM
HOMEOWNERS AND BUSINESSES. WE
HAVE TO BURN OFF ENERGY WE
OPPOSE AB TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE
AND ASK THAT YOU VOTE NO. QUIEN. TWO FIFTY TWO. HELLO MY NAME
IS BRENDA BALCAZAR AND IDW
NUMBER AND I'M CALLING IN TO
SUPPORT EACH YEAR. ONE FOR
THIRTY. PINE TO FIFTY NINE.
REBECCA BAND I AM AN IBEW MEMBER
AS WELL AND I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. NINE TWO EIGHTY SEVEN.
THIS MY NAME IS BOB QUINN I'M
THE OWNER OF SKY POWER SALUTE.
FIRST SOLAR CONTRACTOR IN SAN
RAMON. COOLEY ABOUT SIXTEEN
PEOPLE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
TWENTY YEARS WE ARE AGAINST THIS
BILL INCLUDE YOU TO VOTE NO
THANK YOU. FINE. TWO NINETY
SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS YET TO GET
THINGS CAPABLE COLLECTED A LOT
BEACH CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED
WILL BE TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE
WEST OF THE VOTE NO ON THE BILL-
FIRST OF ALL THE COLLECTIVE
RECORD- YOU CAN CURRENT GOAL HAS
A WHAT SORT AND SO FINALLY WE
GOT YOUR POSITION SIR THANK YOU
. OKAY NAME ORGANIZATION ISRAEL
EIGHT. FOUR FIVE THREE ZERO
NUMBER. YEAH MY NAME IS RENEE
COULD MARTINEZ AND I AM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF IBEW LOCAL TWELVE
FORTY FIVE AND WE'RE CALLING IN
THE COURT OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU. PINE THREE
ELEVEN. HI MY NAME IS JASON
MARION I'M THE OWNER OF TRINITY
POWER HERE IN FRESNO CALIFORNIA
AND WE EMPLOY ABOUT TWENTY THREE
PEOPLE- FOR COMMERCIAL AND
RESIDENTIAL SOLAR- WE SPEND A
LOT OF MONEY AND TIME TRAINING
OUR EMPLOYEES- THEY COME FROM
VERY LOW INCOME FAMILIES
TYPICALLY IN THE FRESNO AREA WE
PROVIDE THEM HEALTH CARE- WE
WORK ON SAFETY WE TRAIN AND-
GIVEN THEM OSHA TEN AND OSHA
THIRTY CERTIFICATIONS WE HAVE
COOL PROGRAMS- IN WE ARE
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO AB TWO ONE
FOUR THREE IT WILL TAKE AWAY OUR
BUSINESS 1100% WE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE WORKING IF THIS
PASSES. THANK YOU. OVERALL LINE
THREE EIGHTEEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON ANTONIO SANCHEZ AND ON
BEHALF OF I. T. W. LOCAL ELEVEN
A LOS ANGELES R. TWELVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS WE FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. A LINE. THREE
FIFTEEN. PAUL WHAT'S ON BEHALF
OF THE SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. PINE
THREE TWENTY. HELLO MY NAME IS
JOE RYAN I OWN A SMALL BUSINESS
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF MY BUSINESS I OPPOSE AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE AND A
HALF THAT YOU VOTE NO. PINE
THREE TWENTY ONE. I AM JAMES
SHEPHERD FROM- HELP LOWER AND
PETS ROBLES CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY
BOND CUNNINGHAM DISTRICT- WE A
HAVE BEEN IN BUSINESS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE- WE PAY I
DON'T KNOW WHO GETS AWAY WITH
PAYING TWENTY THREE DOLLARS AN
HOUR E WOULD NEED TO CONSIDER
THAT ARE EVER TO PAY IS OVER
THIRTY SIX DOLLARS AN HOUR OUR
HIGHEST PEOPLE ARE. OF HIGH.
THIRTY DOLLAR RANGE HOW. CAN
ANYBODY WHO THINKS THAT THE ONLY
ELEVEN PERCENT OF OUR- OF OUR
CAR IS CRAZY YOU WHEN YOU ADD IN
THE- RECONSTRUCTION AS WELL AS
THE- ALECTRA TODAY IT'S MORE
LIKE TWENTY. TO TWENTY TWO
PERCENT. OF THE TOTAL SIR THANK
YOU FOR STATING YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. OF
LINE THREE TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S GERALD
WILLIAMS I'M A PROUD IBEW MEMBER
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO ONE
FOUR THREE. THANK YOU. TWO
EIGHTY SIX. HELLO THIS IS GREG
KENNEDY WITH OCCIDENTAL POWER
SOLAR COMPANY IN SAN FRANCISCO-
OVER FORTY YEARS IN THE BUSINESS
HERE- WHEN WE NEED PREVAILING
WAGE WE HIRE- WE HAVE A LONG
HISTORY IN PUBLIC HOUSING SOLAR
AND HIRING FROM THE LOWER
PRIVILEGE COMMUNITIES AND IT
WOULD BE VERY DETRIMENTAL TO
VOTE FOR THIS MEASURE IT WOULD
PUT A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT OF WORK
AND HE WOULD KILL A MARKET BASED
ECONOMY NOT SURE I THINK. I
THINK I'M GONNA I'M GONNA JUST
A- REMIND FOLKS ADIGA BEEN
PRETTY FAIR AT DINNER ONE ONE
WHERE SOME FOLKS HAVE GONE A
LITTLE WHILE LONGER THAN JUST
THEIR. JUST ASK EVERYONE IF
THEY'LL STICK TO THE RULES. NAME
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION
PLEASE THANK YOU. NINE TO FORTY
SEVEN. OVANDO LINE THREE THIRTY
THREE. HELLO MY NAME IS NICK
THAT HE CALLED HIM A FULL TANK
FELLER A LICENSED CONTRACTOR IN
GLENDALE CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY THREE THANK YOU. BLIND TWO
FIFTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS CHARLOTTE STEVENS MY
MEMBER ID W. TWELVE FORTY FIVE I
CAN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY THREE. NO FURTHER ON THE
PHONE LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THE BILL THANK YOU WE HAVE
A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL- PRIOR
SECOND. ARE WE WILL BRING IT
BACK FOR QUESTIONS AND I'M ASK
IF ANYONE HAS ANY QUESTIONS OF
ART TO WITNESSES HERE OR THE
AUTHOR AND THEN IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE- TESTIMONY
THAT WAS GIVEN BY. THE
PROPONENTS YEAH BUT- TOM. MISTER
ROGERS CAN I. I'D LIKE TO ASK
ABOUT THE- I REPRESENT CENTER
CALIFORNIA THE FRESNO AREA AND
AGRICULTURE IS UNDER A GREAT
DEAL OF STRESS- WE HAVE- LOTS OF
AG GROUND BEING FOLLOWED. OUR AT
OUR- PACKING HOUSES ARE ARE
TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO SAVE
MONEY AT SO VERY LARGE SCALE-
PROJECTS IN CENTER CALIFORNIA ON
FELLOW DAG GROUND- THEY ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS WITH
RESPECT TO COST. AND ALSO ALMOST
EVERY ROOF TOP. OF OUR PACKING
HOUSES THAT YOU CAN FIND THEIR
THEIR- ONE TO PUT UP MORE AND
MORE AND- I HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH SOME OF MAGRA CULTURAL
PEOPLE YESTERDAY ABOUT THIS-
THERE IS A CONCERN THERE AND I
REGISTER THAT CONCERN. ERA AND
WOULD ASK- IF YOU WATER. RESPOND
TO THAT- BUT IT IS A IT IS A
SERIOUS CONCERN THAT GIVES ME
PAUSE ON MY VOTE. YES MR VICE
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION. I WILL DIG IN PRO
AFTER THIS HEARING TO TRY TO GET
MORE. SPECIFIC DATA ON
AGRICULTURE BECAUSE IT WASN'T
READILY AVAILABLE THIS LATE
TODAY WHEN YOU'RE STAFFERS AT
EACH WITH ME. I CAN'T TELL YOU
THAT IT'S MY BELIEF THAT THERE'S
LESS NET METERING OF- OF SOLAR
ENERGY IN AG BUSINESSES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THEN IN OTHER
SECTORS. FOR THE FACT THAT WE
WORKED WITH AND SUPPORTED
QUESTIONS HE DIDN'T PPOSE
LEGISLATION TO ALLOW
AGRIBUSINESS TO SITE SOLAR ON
THEIR FACILITIES. AND THEN WE'LL
THE POWER IN BETWEEN VARIOUS
DIFFERENT FACILITIES THAT THEY
MAIL. WHICH WE RESISTED FOR A
VERY LONG TIME US LIKE GALLO FOR
INSTANCE COULD HAVE SOLAR VERY
DIFFERENT MEDIA THEY'RE
DIFFERENT YOU KNOW- WAREHOUSES
AND WHATNOT. THE OVER GENERATE
RIGHT HERE THEY CAN WE'LL IT TO
ANOTHER LOCATION- SO I DON'T
HAVE THE DATA SPECIFIC TO YOU
AND SO I WILL GET THAT TO YOU
BUT THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I CAN
TELL YOU DABABNEH PRESET THAT.
STRETCH- I WILL LAY OFF THE BILL
UP. BUT WOULD CERTAINLY RESERVE
A VOTE FOR THE FLOOR BUT I DO
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE EFFECT ON
LOT OF A LARGE SCALE. SOLAR
THAT'S BEING UP. PUT IN OUR AREA
BECAUSE OF FALLOW AG THE WATER
ISSUE. AND ALSO THE HIGH COST
OF- OTHER ELECTRICITY-
AGRICULTURE'S UNDER REAL STRESS
THAT THIS IS A STRESSOR. ON TOP
OF THE OTHER STRESSORS I'LL HAVE
TO I'LL HAVE TO PAUSE FOR THIS
AND IF I MAY RESPOND WITH- JUST
A DIFFERENT VIEWPOINT AS WELL
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND I
BELIEVE ALSO IN YOUR DISTRICT.
YOU'RE SEEING A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING THE
SHUTDOWN OF FOSSIL FUELS AND
WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE WORKERS IN
YOUR COMMUNITY AND ACROSS A
CENTRAL VALLEY AND ACROSS
CALIFORNIA FOR STUCK IN A
POSITION OF IF WE SHUT DOWN A
CERTAIN INDUSTRY. THEN WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE AN INCREASE OF
SOLAR WHICH IS WHAT WE ALL WANT
IN TERMS OF CLEAN GREEN ENERGY.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE WORKERS. AND
WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE WAGES AND
WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE PENSIONS
AND WHAT HAPPENS TO THAT KIND
OF. SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. SO THAT'S ALSO
SOMETHING THAT YOUR COMMUNITY
AND YOUR DISTRICT IS TRYING TO
REACH WITH. WE DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF OIL IN MY DISTRICT. ARE
WORKERS AROUND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY I APPRECIATE THAT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT. AGRICULTURE
BEING UNDER HUGE COST AND
REGULATORY STRESSORS UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA PUT OUT A OF.
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS WITH RESPECT
TO WHAT THE GROUND MANAGEMENT
DATA IS DOING I MEAN WE WERE
TELLING OUR AG PEOPLE DON'T PUMP
IT OUT OF THE GROUND BUT WE'RE
NOT GETTING THE SERVICE WATER TO
PUT IT BACK IN THE GROUND. AND
WE THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE A
HALF A MILLION COULD BE A
MILLION ACRES FALLOW AND ALL OF
OUR AGRICULTURAL PEOPLE ARE
SCRAMBLING TO FIND WAYS. TO
SUPPLANT. INCOME UP IT TO
REPURPOSE AND ONE OF THE-
SIGNIFICANT RE PURPOSING IS IN
LARGE SCALE. SOLAR ARRAYS- AND I
JUST NEED ASSURANCES THAT- THAT
THIS ISN'T GOING TO BE OUT OF IN
ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT ADD ON TO
THE PRICE TAG OF FARMING AND IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WE NEED
OPTIONS ON THOSE GROUNDS. AT
SOLAR IS AN OPTION ON THAT AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT- THIS IS
NOT AN IN INCREASED A DRIVER OF
THOSE COSTS WE HAVE MANY OF. THE
COMPANY'S LOCAL. THAT DO LARGE
SCALE AG. AND I JUST DIDN'T HAVE
NOT HAD TIME FRANKLY BECAUSE
THIS CAME TO ME QUICKLY.
YESTERDAY AND I'M DOING MY
HOMEWORK. AND LIKE I SAID A
LITTLE WAY OFF HERE TODAY. WE
HAVE- QUESTIONS FROM SOME MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND THEN- MISTER
MURATSUCHI. FOLLOWED BY THIS
HOLD. WHAT IF ANYONE ADDRESS
MISTER WHAT IF I MAY MISTER
CHAIR. AND WHEN ASKED HIM TO DO
A LITTLE DEEPER MAYBE REPEAT
SOME OF THE FINDINGS AND THAT UC
BERKELEY STUDY- ON PREVAILING
WAGE IF IN A AND I ALSO WANNA- I
DON'T KNOW IF I CAUGHT THIS
EARLIER BUT WHO ALSO PAID FOR
THAT STUDY BUT PRETTY GOOD
DELIVER DEEPER OUT OF PUSHING
THAT- THIS STUDY WAS
COMMISSIONED LAST YEAR BY THE
STATE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSING BOARD. AND THEY WENT
OUT TO BID AND THEY SELECTED THE
UC BERKELEY TO CONDUCT A STUDY.
THEY FOUND THAT LABOR COSTS OF A
PERCENTAGE OF TOTAL ROOFTOP
SOLAR PROJECTS REYES BETWEEN SIX
AND 11% AND THAT IF- IF YOU
ASSUME THAT UP IT PREVAILING
WAGE WOULD ACCOUNT FOR A 50%
INCREASE IN LABOR COSTS WHICH IT
DOESN'T KNOW DEMONSTRATE THAT A
MOMENT THAT THAT WOULD THEN
RESULT IN A TOTAL INCREASE IN
COST OF THREE TO FIVE PERCENT.
OKAY THEY ALSO FOUND THAT THE
AVERAGE SOLAR INSTALLER IN
CALIFORNIA MAKES A LITTLE OVER
TWENTY THREE DOLLARS AN HOUR
WITHOUT BENEFITS I JUST GRABBED
SACRAMENTO REALLY WAGE RATE OFF
THE DEPARTMENT INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS NO THIS IS A
RESIDENTIAL INSIDE WIREMAN RAPES
OF REBUILDING A SOLAR ARRAY ON
A- ON A ON A HOME. THE
PREVAILING WAGE RATE
SACRAMENTO'S THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS
AND FIFTY CENTS AN HOUR FOR A
FOR A FOR A RESIDENTIAL
ELECTRICIANS. RIGHT HERE. WITH
AN ADDITIONAL SIXTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR GOING TO HEALTH AND WELFARE
OF PENSION AND TRAINING- HOPE
THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION. THE
COMPUTER THE OPPOSITION STATED A
DIFFERENT NUMBER THAT WAS A
LITTLE OUT OF LINE WITH WHAT
I'VE HEARD YOU SAY NINE OUT I
DON'T THINK YOU CAN ANSWER THEM
BUT IT GIVE ANY THOUGHTS ON
RECONCILING THE TWO DIFFERENT.
NUMBERS YOU KNOW. IT IT VARIES
WITH INDIVIDUAL COMPANIES- IF
THE FIGURES THAT WERE SHARED BY
A COUPLE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
PHONED IN WERE ACCURATE THEN
THEY SHOULD HAVE ANY PROBLEM
MEDIAN TO PREVENT A WAGE
SCHEDULE IN IN IN THEIR AREA. I
DON'T REALLY BUY THAT IT'S YOU
KNOW UC BERKELEY DID A PRETTY
THOROUGH STUDY AND WE KNOW WHAT
WE SEE OUT. IT IN IN THE
LANDSCAPE. A. N. AGAIN THIS WAS
NOT A STUDY DONE FOR THE I. B.
W. THIS WAS AN INDEPENDENT STUDY
PERFORMED FOR THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSING BOARD. A FOLLOW
UP QUESTION SIR OKAY. WE WANT TO
A MISTER MESSAGING. THANK THANK
YOU- LET ME LET ME SAY FROM THE
OUTSET I WANT TO MAKE IT
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT I. SUPPORT. A MIDDLE CLASS WAGE. FOR A
ROOFTOP SOLAR INSTALLERS AND I
SUPPORT A PREVAILING WAGE. FOR
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS. BUT AT
THE SAME TIME I THINK WE ALL
AGREE THAT WE NEED MORE SOLAR.
ACROSS THE BOARD. ROUGH TOP
UTILITY SCALE IN ORDER TO MEET
OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND TO SAVE
OUR PLANET. AND SO I THINK
THAT'S THE DIFFICULT BALANCING
ACT HERE- HOW DO WE. TAKE CARE
OF OUR WORKERS WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME- INCENTIVIZE MORE AND MORE
SOLAR SO THAT WE CAN CUT DOWN
ON. FOSSIL FUEL USE SO THAT WE
CAN. FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE AND
SAVE OUR PLANET. I SHARE MISTER
WATCHES GOAL OF. GETTING MORE
SOLAR ON EVERY ROOFTOP INCLUDING
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES- ONE
OF MY CONCERNS IS THAT IF THIS
INCREASES COSTS ON SOLAR THAT IS
GOING TO MAKE IT. MORE EXPENSIVE
MORE DIFFICULT FOR. BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES TO GET SOLAR ON THE
ROOFTOPS- AND SO I WANTED. TO
MAKE THAT CLEAR AND SO LET ME
JUMP INTO SOME OF MY SPECIFIC
CONCERNS MY NUMBER ONE CONCERN.
IS THE PRECEDENT THAT THIS BILL
IS PROPOSING ARE BY. PROPOSING
TO CLASSIFY. A PRIVATE SOLAR
INSTALLATION PROJECT AS A PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECT IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR PREVAILING WAGE. HOW
IS IT THAT A PRIVATE SOLAR YOU
KNOW INSULATION. BECOMES A
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT. MISTER
WHICH- YES IS A MEMBER
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION WELL ACTUALLY THIS
ISN'T BREAKING NEW GROUND IN
ACTUALLY IT IS A CREATING A
PRECEDENT. FIRST AND FOREMOST
RATEPAYER DOLLARS TRIGGER
PREVENT WAGE IN MANY INSTANCES
FIRST AND FOREMOST. SB MUNICIPAL
UTILITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EVERY PENNY THEY
SPEND OF RATEPAYER MONEY ON
PROJECTS REQUIRES PREVENT WAGE.
YOU VOTED IN TWENTY TWENTY FIRST
SIMPLY BILL EIGHT FORTY ONE BY
YOUR COLLEAGUE MR TANG. WHICH
SHIFTED THREE BILLION DOLLARS
RATEPAYER MONEY IN ENERGY
EFFICIENCY. TO THE FROM THE P.
YOU SEE TO THE ENERGY CMMISSION
AND REQUIRED THE PAYMENT OF
PREVAILING WAGE AND A SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE. AND
LASTLY PROBABLY THE GREATEST
PRESIDENT. IS THAT ENOUGH.
TWENTY FIFTEEN. A PERIOD WHEN
YOU WERE HERE. THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB THREE FIFTY BY THEN
PRESIDENT PRO TEM KEVIN DE LEÓN
. WHICH REQUIRED ALL
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS THERE ARE
PAID FOR THE REPAIR DOLLARS
WHICH ARE ALL OF THEM. PAPERMAN
WHICH. THOSE DOLLARS THAT WE
SPEND ON TRANSMISSION. DWARF
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE BY
APPLYING PREVAILING WAGE TO ONLY
THE 3% OF THE LARGEST ROOFTOP
SOLAR PROJECTS ARE GETTING-
SUBSIDIZED SERVICE TO WATCH ALL
OF THOSE- PRECEDENT THAT YOU
DECIDED. THOSE WERE ALL UTILITY
SCALE PROJECTS. NO WHEN WE WENT
WHEN YOU GO IN AND HAVE IT IN
YOU YOU PUT IN A- YOU PICK THE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROJECT THE
MONEY THAT WE WOULD GET YOU
VOTED FOR TO TAKE. FROM THE C.
YOU SEE IN THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROGRAM AND THINK AND- AND HAVE
THE C. E. C. ADMINISTER IT. GOES
TO ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS SMALL AND
LARGE. I REMEMBER VOTING FOR A
BILL THAT SUPPORTED. THAT
IMPOSED A PREVAILING WAGE
REQUIREMENT FOR THOSE TYPE OF
PROJECTS BUT DID THOSE TYPE OF
PROJECTS GET CLASSIFIED
INCLUDING NON UTILITY SCALE
PRIVATE PROJECTS ARE THEY
CONSIDERED PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS. THOSE PROJECTS- WERE
DESIGNATED PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS
BY THE BY EIGHT FORTY ONE WHICH
DESIGNATED THEM AS PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS IN AN ASSIGNED THE
SPENDING OF RATEPAYER DOLLARS
THERE. BUT THERE'S OTHER
PRESIDENTS OF PRIVATE PROJECTS
YOU VOTED FOR SB FIFTY FOUR
WHICH REQUIRED THAT PREVAILING
WAGE BE PAID ON ALL WORK
PERFORMED AT OIL AND GAS
FACILITIES. WHICH ARE PRIVATE
PROJECTS BUT BECAUSE ITS OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY I GUESS THAT'S
ACCEPTABLE TO YOU. IT WAS THAT'S
WHY VOTE FOR THE BILL I SUPPORT
PREVAILING WAGE FOR LARGE
PROJECTS. BUT AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. INTEL THE POLICY
BEHIND PAYING A PREVAILING WAGE
. IS TO ENSURE THAT CONTRACTORS
ARE NOT AWARD TO PUBLIC WORKS
CONTRACTS BY UNDERCUTTING
COMPETITORS WHO PROVIDE- HIGHER
COMPENSATION IT'S THE INTENT OF
THE PREVAILING WAGE IS TO CREATE
A LOT LEVEL PLAYING FIELD BY
REQUIRING ACROSS THE BOARD RATE
FOR ALL BIDDERS ON PUBLICLY
SUBSIDIZED PROJECTS. WE'RE
TALKING HERE. YOU KNOW YOU
MENTIONED- FIFTEEN KILOWATTS- OF
A PROJECT IS SIXTY NINE PANELS I
HEARD I HEARD FROM. THE
OPPOSITION THAT ITS IT'S-
SOMETHING SMALLER BUT BE THAT AS
IT MAY IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW SOLAR PROJECTS ON THEIR
OWN LARGE HOMES AS WE GET MORE
HOMES COULD BE COMING
ELECTRIFIED OR ON COMMERCIAL
PROJECTS. YOU WANT US TO
CONSIDER THESE TYPE OF PROJECTS
TO BE PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS. YET
MISS RESEARCH A SEVENTEEN TWENTY
OF THE LABOR CODE DEFINES PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS AS ANY PROJECT
THAT RECEIVES THE ANY PROJECT
WHERE THERE'S CAN DEMOLITION
ALTERATION. OR CONSTRUCTION
WHERE THEY'RE PAID FOR IN WHOLE
OR IN PART THROUGH PUBLIC FUNDS
AND THEN IT GOES ON TO DEFINE
THOSE PUBLIC THOSE PUBLIC FUNDS
IS ANY SORT OF SUBSIDY OF ANY
SORT INCLUDING IF THEY IF THE
CITY WAVES A DEVELOPER FEES OR
GIVES A GRANT OF ANY SIZE. IT IT
TRIGGERS THAT AND THEN THE
LEGISLATURE HAS GONE IN AND
DEEMED CERTAIN TYPES OF
SUBSIDIES. TO TRIGGER PREVAILING
WAGE AND WHAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BILL SUGGESTS HERE IS IF
A LARGE SCALE ROOFTOP SOLAR
PROJECT IS RECEIVING. SUBSIDIES
OF WHICH THESE PROJECTS ARE
RECEIVING MULTIPLE TYPES OF
SUBSIDIES BUT IN THIS CASE ANNAM
SUBSIDY. THAT THAT SHOULD
TRIGGER PREVAILING WAGE OKAY SO
FOLLOWING ON THAT POINT. IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SUBSIDIES OF
PUBLIC FUNDS. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT BE MA'AM
TARIFF. IS NOT A PUBLIC FUND BUT
IT'S WHAT. THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL AND OTHERS HAVE CALLED THE
COST SHIFT YOUR IN OTHER WORDS
IT'S RATE PAYERS THAT PAY NOT
PUBLIC FUNDS AND YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY 1100% CORRECT IT'S
RATE PAYER MONIES. JUST LIKE THE
THREE INSTANCES THAT I OUTLINED
WHERE THIS LEGISLATURE IN ITS
WISDOM DECIDED TO SAY THAT
RATEPAYER MONEY GOING FOR THAT
PURPOSE SHOULD BE PAID SHOULD
SHOULD BE COVERED BY PREVAILING
WAGE TRANSMISSION IN AB EIGHT
FORTY ONE AND THEN OF COURSE THE
FACT THAT ALL WORK DONE BY
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES THAT SPEND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS RATEPAYER
MONEY ALSO TRIGGERS PROPERLY
WHICH- MY CONCERN IS THAT. WHILE. THIS PROJECT IS TALKING ABOUT
. YOU KNOW ANYWHERE I UNDERSTAND
BETWEEN FORTY TWO TO SIXTY NINE
PANELS IN ORDER TO GENERATE A
LOAD OF FIFTEEN KILOWATTS- WHAT
IS TO STOP. THE NEXT BILL TO GO
AFTER ALL SOLAR PROJECTS TO BE
CLASSIFIED AS PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS. THAT CERTAINLY BE YOUR
PER PROVOCATIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
. AND I THINK THAT IS. THE
CONCERN I'D LIKE TO- ASK A AND
THE OPPOSITION. WHAT IS THE
TYPICAL- LOAD- SOLAR PROJECT- IT
AND THE LOW TAT A SERVICE FOR
YOUR YOUR YOUR TYPICAL HOME.
THANK YOU THAT'S IT I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER THAT A TYPICAL
RESIDENTIAL INSTALLATION IN OUR
AREA IS ABOUT SEVEN TO TEN
KILOWATTS- AND THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT THAT WE HELPED GO
SOLAR WAS THREE FIRE HOUSES FOR
A TOTAL OF ABOUT SEVENTY EIGHT
KILOWATTS- TO HELP. CLARIFY
WHAT- MISTER WHICH SAID EARLIER
IT'S NOT KILOWATT HOURS THAT
SOLAR PANELS PRODUCE ITS
KILOWATTS WHICH IS A MEASURE OF
POWER WERE AS KILOWATT HOURS IS
A MEASURE OF STORED ENERGY. SO
A- SYSTEM THAT HAS SIXTY NINE
PANELS THE NUMBER OF PANELS
ISN'T WHAT WHAT'S IMPORTANT IT'S
THE NUMBER OF WATTS PER PANEL SO
ON A TYPICAL WATERS FOR PANELS
NOW IS FOUR HUNDRED WATTS SO IF
YOU HAVE TEN PANELS OF FOUR
HUNDRED WATTS EACH THAT'S FOUR
KILOWATTS. SO A SYSTEM OF FORTY
KILL FORTY PANELS WOULD BE
SIXTEEN KILOWATTS WHICH IS MORE
THAN THE FIFTEEN KILOWATTS
THAT'S PROPOSED IN THIS BILL. SO
AND IF I MAY COULD I ALSO JUST
MENTION AS A SINGLE POINT OF
REFERENCE IN. COMPARISON TO WHAT
MR WHICH HAS SAID ABOUT
PREVAILING WAGE I HAVE A BRAND
NEW A HIGH SCHOOL GRDUATE FROM
OAKLAND MICHAEL ESPINOZA. HE HAS
NO SOUL OR EXPERIENCE I PAID HIM
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR- AND
WHEN WE DID THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
PROJECT I HAD TO PAY HIM EIGHTY
FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR FOR
PREVAILING WAGE FOR AN INSIDE
WIRE MEN WHICH SHE IS NOT- AND I
WHAT. SHOULD BE IDEA OF EQUITY
YOU'RE ADDING COSTS TO SOLAR IS
NOT GOING TO HELP BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES GOT MORE SOLAR
SO THAT'S A FLAW AND SECONDLY.
THE PREVAILING WAGE SYSTEM IS SO
ANTIQUATED AND COMPLICATED I
CAN'T BELIEVE ANYBODY CAN USE IT
DO YOU KNOW WHEN I WENT TO GO
LOOK UP WHAT DO I PAY MY GUYS I
COULDN'T FIND SOLAR INSTALLER I
COULD FIND HARD CARRIER DOES
ANYONE KNOW WHAT HARD CARE YOUR
IS. IT SOMEONE WHO CARRIES
BRICKS FOR A BRICK WHERE.
THERE'S PROBABLY CANDLE MAKE AND
BUGGY WHIP MAKERS IN THIS LIST
BUT NOT SOLAR INSTALLERS SO. I
JUST I THINK IT'S IN. IT'S IN
NEED OF SOME RETOOLING TO BE
HELPING US MODERNIZE OUR GRID
AND I THINK I'VE ALREADY. MADE
MY OTHER POINTS ABOUT HOW WE PAY
A FAIR WAGE AND GIVE GOOD
BENEFITS PAYING AT A HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE EIGHTY FIVE DOLLARS. IS
NOT FAIR THANK YOU CAN YOU
FOLLOW QUESTIONS MR MUCH
REACHING UP IF I MAY YOU KNOW
JUST. ONE OR TWO MORE QUESTIONS
SO. IT SOUNDS LIKE THIS PROPOSAL
IS FOR- REQUIRING PREVAILING
WAGE ON ON THE INSTALLATION OF-
ROOFTOP SOLAR- OVER FIFTEEN
KILOWATTS. SO IT SOUNDS LIKE ALL
COMMERCIAL SO MY CHARITY MY WIFE
HOMELESS SERVICES CHARITY THAT
WOULD HAVE REQUIRED IT MY
DENTIST WOULD HAVE REQUIRED IT
THE APARTMENT BUILDING IN A LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOOD WOULD HAVE
REQUIRED IT THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
REQUIRED BECAUSE IT WAS A PUBLIC
WORKS AND THEY HAD A PUBLIC
WORKS BUDGET. BUT THESE OTHER
CUSTOMERS OF MINE THEY DON'T
OKAY SO I HEAR YOU THAT TO. IT
SOUNDS LIKE. YOU KNOW COMMERCIAL
OR PUBLIC OR BUILDINGS WITH
PUBLIC USE LIKE NONPROFITS MAY
HAVE EASILY EXCEED FIFTEEN
KILOWATTS. DEFINITELY OKAY BUT
BUT YOUR TYPICAL THIS WOULD NOT.
IMPACT YOUR TYPICAL HOME IT
WOULD NOT IMPACT A TYPICAL
RESIDENTIAL INSTALLATION IT
WOULD IMPACT SOME HIGHER END
INSTALLATIONS. AND YOU KNOW YOU
COULD MAKE AN ARGUMENT THAT-
THAT THAT'S FAIR BUT I COULD
MAKE THE OPPOSING ARGUMENT THAT
WHEN YOU ARE TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE TO PART WITH THEIR
CAPITAL TO INVEST IN. EQUIPMENT
TO MAKE ENERGY TO HELP US ALL GO
SOLAR IT'S THE PEOPLE WITH THE
MEANS THAT ARE GOING TO DO IT.
SO IF WE WANT TO PUNISH THEM BY
MAKING IT MORE EXPENSIVE THAN WE
SHOULD YOU KNOW GO AHEAD AND
REQUIRE PREVAILING WAGE FOR A
PRIVATE HOMEOWNER TO ADD SOLAR
TO HIS HOUSE. THANK YOU HAVE
NOTHING THANK YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
FROM. MISTER HOLD. THERE'S A LOT
TO UNPACK IT ALL OF THAT I'M NOT
SURE HOW MUCH I WANT TO DELVE
INTO SOME OF THE POINTS HAVE
BEEN MADE BUT I THINK THAT. I'LL
JUST MAKE A- KIND OF A THIRTY
THOUSAND FOOT OBSERVATION HERE
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
FOR COMING BACK AND TRYING TO
ATTACK THIS ISSUE AND IT IS AN
ISSUE. AND I THINK IT'S CLEAR
AND I'LL GRANT YOU THE POINT
THAT- THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT PROBABLY NEED TO BE
RETOOLED- GOOD- IF ONE WERE TO
DIG INTO THEIR- THE CODES AND-
ALL OF THAT YOU COULD PROBABLY
SEE SOME OTHER AREAS- NOT JUST
AT THE STATE LEVEL BUT AT A
LOCAL LEVEL. BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY THE THING THAT I'M-
STOCK. HERE IN MY MIND. IS THAT
THERE'S A PARADOX THAT'S
EMERGING. ONE WHERE WE'RE SAYING
WE'VE GOT TO GET OFF OF FOSSIL
FUEL. AND WE ALL AGREE WE NEED
TO GET OFF OF FOSSIL FUEL. BUT
IT'S ALSO INTERESTING THAT IS
THE FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY THAT'S
PAYING THE SAME WORKERS SIX
FIGURES. IN INCOME A YEAR. AND
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT TRYING TO
BRIDGE THAT GAP. THE AREA THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE THE
TRANSITION TO THAT INDUSTRY.
OBVIOUSLY IS NOT GOING TO BE
PAYING SIX FIGURES. BECAUSE
WE'RE STRUGGLING AT WHAT
PREVAILING WAGE LOOKS LIKE. BUT
IT IS A STEP IN THE DIRECTION
AND I'M NOT DIMINISHING SOME OF
YOUR CONCERNS THAT YOU'VE
RAISED. BUT IT IS NECESSARY TO
TRY TO BRIDGE THE GAP. TERMS OF
WAGE AND WHAT THAT MEANS AND
DATA IS IMPORTANT I APPRECIATE
THE OF THE- STUDY THAT UC
BERKELEY HAS DONE THAT'S BEEN
PRESENTED TO US THAT'S
INFORMATION TO HELP IN
PROCESSING I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
THAT SAYS TO THE CONTRARY
ALTHOUGH. I TAKE YOUR TESTIMONY
TO BE VALID ON ITS FACE- BUT
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS OF WHAT
I THINK THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH NOW MICHAEL BILLS
THIS IS THE FIRST COMMITTEE. AND
SO I'M ASSUMING AND I'M HOPING
THAT CERTAINLY THE AUTHOR. AND
THE SPONSOR WILL BE AMENABLE TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS I
THINK THEY'VE ALREADY
DEMONSTRATED THAT TO THE VICE
CHAIR AS IT RELATES TO THE
IMPACT ON AGRICULTURE AND- WHAT.
THAT ULTIMATELY MAY MEAN TO THE
BUSINESS SECTOR IN HIS DISTRICT.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT BUT
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
COMPETITION THIS IS THE SAME
LANGUAGE. THAT WAS IN YOUR BILL
LAST YEAR AND- GONZALEZ IS BILL
TO ADDRESS THIS. PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE WE'RE WE'RE STILL DEALING
WITH TO SOME DEGREE- CAUTIOUS-
WITH THE NUMBER- OF GRAHAM- THE
REGULATORY AGENCY IS GOT A
DECISION BEFORE IT WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO. WAIT TO SEE WHAT THAT
YIELDS- AND SO I'M PREPARED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL I'M- OBVIOUSLY-
HOPEFUL AND BELIEVING THAT. SOME
OF THE IMPORTANT POINTS THAT
HAVE COME OUT IN THIS
CONVERSATION CAN BE PART OF
FURTHER DISCUSSION. AND I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES-
EXPLORING IN PULLING. OF SOME OF
THE LAYERS OF THE ONION BACK. OF
US IN HERE STERN TO GET TEARY
EYED AS YOU'RE DOING IT BUT-
APPRECIATE THAT- BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT. A LOT OF WHAT- THE
AUTHOR HAS PRESENTED IN HER
OPENING STATEMENT. WHAT WAS
MISTER WHICH IS. PRESENTED IN
HIS OF DEFENSE OF THE PROGRAM
DEFENSE OF THE BILL- HAS A LOT
OF MERIT AS WELL AND SO. I'M
PREPARED TO MOVE FORWARD. WITH
THE BILL TODAY AND CONTINUE TO
HOPE THAT THEY'LL BE
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN- OF THE
PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS TO. SEE
IF THERE'S SOME OTHER ELEMENTS
OF. OF MODIFICATIONS THAT CAN BE
LOOKED AT AS FAIR AND REASONABLE
AND- AN INTEGRATED INTO THE BILL
IN SOME FORM. RIGHT THANK YOU I
BELIEVE. WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
MISPRICED. THIS BY MRS FROM
NAMASTE. BUT I WILL CONTINUE TO
ASK QUESTIONS. SOPHISTICATES
QUICK WITH A QUICK CAR WITH THE
QUICK COMMENT I KNOW THE HOUR IS
LATE AND- THIS IS THE AND I
THOUGHT MY BUILD PRESENT TO
SERVE. ON FIRST LET LET ME JUST
TAKE OFF THE FOR BRING THIS BILL
BACK ON THE LAST YEAR WE HAD A
ROBUST DISCUSSION WITH. THIS%
BECAUSE ALL HIS BILL AND AS
SOMEONE WHO IS A SOLAR CUSTOMER.
A BIG FAN OF- THE NET ENERGY
METERING SYSTEMATIC IT WAS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO LAUNCH
THE SOLAR INDUSTRY HERE ARE
MILLION ROOF. GOAL WHICH WE DID
HERE I BELIEVE FOR A YEAR TO GO.
I THINK THAT THE VERY PROBLEM AT
THE STATE HAVE HAVING SAID THAT.
I THINK IT'S BEEN YEARS IN THE
MAKING THAT WE NEED TO TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AT HOW WE DO NET
ENERGY METERING. I SOMEONE WHO
SAW BENEFITTED FROM THAT
PERSONALLY SINCE- TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVEN WHEN I INSTALLED MY
OWN SOLAR INSTALLATION- I THINK
IT IS TIME THAT WE TAKE ANOTHER
LOOK. AT THE SYSTEM. I DON'T
THINK THAT THE P. SEE OUT A
RIGHT WHICH IS NOT A- BY THE
THREE OF US TO BE ON THIS
COMMITTEE FOR QUITE AWHILE. IT'S
MUCH BETTER THAT WE TAKE A LOOK
AT IT FROM A LEGISLATIVE POINT
OF VIEW. AND I KNOW THAT. THEIR
LOT OF STRONG FEELINGS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THIS ISSUE I REALLY
WOULD URGE HOPE THE HOPE IS THAT
WE CAN. YOU KNOW THE PARTIES CAN
COME TOGETHER AND REACH A
COMPROMISE AND I THINK
UNFORTUNATELY WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
REACH THAT. OUT LAST YEAR- BUT
MY HOPE IS THIS YEAR THAT WE CAN
REACH IT. AND THAT WE CAN FIND
SOME. COMMON GROUND BETWEEN THE
INDUSTRY AND I THINK BETWEEN ALL
THE COMMUNITIES WHO. ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT. THE ENERGY
METERING SO. WHILE I'M- A HUGE.
FAN PROPONENT OF. NOT RICHARD
MIDDLE SOLAR VERY EARLY
CUSTOMER. EARLY ADOPTER. AT THIS
POINT I'M- HAPPY TO AGAIN
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION LIKE I
DID LAST YEAR. I THINK THAT THIS
DISCUSSION TO BE HAD.
COMPROMISED HIS BEHIND IT WE
NEED TO- FORWARD AND I. THE
AUTHOR FOR ACTUALLY SLIGHTLY ARE
SLIM IN THE BILL DOWN HAVING
MORE FOCUS. ON THIS BILL THAT I
DID LAST YEAR. AND I DO BELIEVE
LIKE- MY COLLEAGUES PASADENA
SAID. THIS IS THE FIRST
COMMITTEE I HOPE IS NOT LOST
COMMITTEE I THINK THAT THIS
DISCUSSION NEEDS TO BE HAD. AND
I MY HOPE IS THAT WE CAN COME
TOGETHER. ON AN AGREEMENT TO
REALLY REFORM POT NET ENERGY
METERING WHICH I THINK AS LONG
BEEN OVER TO. THANK YOU SOME OF
CHANGE I WANT TO SAY THAT- I'VE
APPRECIATED THE- THE DEBATE- IT
WAS A VERY WELL. BROWNED IT AND
IN GOOD SPIRITS- FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ESTABLISHING SOME GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY- THIS ISN'T THE LAST TIME
WE HEAR THIS BILL AND THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY I BELIEVE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED- BY THE- OPPOSITION
WHO HAVE. WEST TESTIFIED TODAY
AND- I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THIS BILL AGAIN. IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
APPROPRIATIONS AND THEN. FOGGO'S
ON THE FLOOR WHERE THAT
COMPROMISE COULD BE PUT FORWARD
HOW WE TWO ARE WAITING FOR A PC.
A DECISION AT SOME POINT. AND
SO- BUT WE CAN'T WAIT FOR THEM
ANYMORE. AND I THINK THAT'S WHY
WERE DELIBERATING THIS ISSUE-
HERE TODAY SO THE THERE'S A
MOTION A SECOND THERE IS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WITH THE
AMENDMENTS- IN IF- DOES HAVE
BEEN ACCEPTED AS A HAVE A AND
ASK IF YOU WANT TO CLOSE. AND-
WILL CALL THE QUESTION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU TO
THE MEMBERS AND TO THE VERY
ROBUST CONVERSATION THAT'S TAKEN
PLACE- REGARDING THIS A
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THERE'S A LOT THAT'S BEEN SAID.
OF THE PUC'S FAILURE TO
ACCIDENTS TWENTY FIFTEEN IS A
CONSTANT CONVERSATION THAT WE
HAVE IN UTILITIES AND ENERGY.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WAIT ON
THEIR DECISION- WHICH CONTINUES
TO BE. AGAIN THE GOAL POSTS
KEEPS MOVING THAT'S ONE SIDE OF
THE CONVERSATION. AS STATED MOST
RESIDENTIAL SOLAR IS ABOUT SIX
KILOWATTS. MAYBE TEN IF THAT.
THE BILL DOES NOT IMPACT THAT.
THIS HAS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO
DO WITH SMALL SCALE RESIDENTIAL
SOLAR FIFTEEN KILOWATTS IT'S
LARGE SCALE. THAT'S A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION. ANYONE
THAT STATES THE PREVAILING WAGE
IS AN ANTIQUATED MODEL IN WHICH
WE- CONSIDER THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. PENSION
PLANS BENEFIT PLANS
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS WHICH
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA AND
SEEKING AN OPPORTUNITY IN A GOOD
UNION JOBS. AS WELL AS
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN-
INDIVIDUALS COMING OUT OF THE
INCARCERATION SYSTEM TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE A GOOD JOB.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS WITHIN
I. B. W. IN THE TRADES ARE A
HUGE PART OF THE ANSWER TO. THAT
QUESTION AND A HUGE PART OF THE
SOLUTION SO PREVAILING WAGE IS
ALREADY SOMETHING THAT
CALIFORNIA LEADS ON A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT PROJECTS. AS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS CONGRESS
CONTINUES TO DEBATE THE GREEN
NEW DEAL. PART OF TE PILLARS OF
THE GREEN NEW DEAL IS TO
ACTUALLY CREATE A CLEAN GREEN.
ENERGY RENEWABLE ENERGY FUTURE
WITH THE WORKERS ALONG SIDE OF
IT. THAT CONVERSATION IS NOT A
SILO CONVERSATION IT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS BY ITSELF
YOU CANNOT CREATE A CLEAN A
GREEN CLEAN GREEN ENERGY FUTURE
AN ECONOMY WITHOUT THE PEOPLE
THAT ACTUALLY SUSTAIN IT. WE ARE
IN THE PROCESS OF DOING THAT AND
THAT'S WHY THESE CONVERSATIONS
ARE COMPLICATED AND THEY ARE
HARD THIS IS MY THIRD ATTEMPT IN
TRYING TO MOVE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS FORWARD WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE PC
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THEM. BUT
THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO ENSURE THAT AT
MINIMUM AND THIS IS HOW WE BEGIN
TO MOVE OUR STATE FORWARD IS
THAT LARGE SCALE FIFTEEN
KILOWATT SOLAR PROJECT INCLUDE
PREVAILING WAGE IF THEY OPT
INTO. THE NUMBER PROGRAM THIS IS
NOT MANDATED THIS IS IF THAT
SOLAR PROJECT DECIDES TO USE
THEM THEY WILL BE SUBJECT TO
PREVAILING WAGE IF THEY CHOOSE
NOT TO. THEN THEY CHOSE NOT TO
AND THIS IS NOT APPLY TO THEM AS
IT DOES NOT APPLY TO SMALL SCALE
RESIDENTIAL SOLAR WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS BILL AS
IT MOVES FORWARD YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THAT SOLUTION LOOKS LIKE ON
ALL SCALES. AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I
PATTERSON- TO NOT VOTING BRYANT.
BRIAN I CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
CHAN AYE CHAN AYE CUNNINGHAM.
ESTELA GARCIA HOLDEN HOLDEN I.
MAYES OUR CITY MURATSUCHI AYE
MEDINA MEDINA I REYES. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I TING TING I RIVAS
RIVAS I. THANK YOU ZERO WE'LL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO WHAT WAS THE SECOND
ITEM ON HE AGENDA A. B. TWENTY
SIX SIXTY SEVEN. SO MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. THE ITEM DOES HAVE A
DO PASS. A COMMENDATION HI AND
NOW TO A BILL WITH NO OPPOSITION
. MOTION WILL. THE SECOND BY
MISTER BRYANT- AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY SEVEN CREATES A NEW
INCENTIVE PROGRAM ADMINISTERED
BY CVC TO SUPPORT INNOVATIVE NEW
APPROACHES AND DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCE ADOPTION BASED
ON THEIR FUNCTIONAL ATTRIBUTES
IN A TECHNOLOGICALLY NEUTRAL
MANNER- THIS IS BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW THERE'S A DISPARITY OF
AVAILABILITY OF INSTEAD OF
SUPPORT- WHERE THE SOME
CUSTOMERS BECAUSE WHO AREN'T IN
A AND I OWE YOU TERRITORY IF
YOU'RE A NEW TERRITORY YOU MIGHT
NOT HAVE ANY OF THIS AVAILABLE
TO YOU SO IN MY DISTRICT FOR
INSTANCE FOR WE HAVE PO USE WE
THE OPTIONS ARE IMITED TO
ONSITE ELECTRIC ELECTRICITY
DEMAND MANAGEMENT. AND SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE COMMUNITY AND I THINK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR HELP TO TRY
TO BRING MORE TECHNOLOGY
AVAILABLE TO ALL DIFFERENT USERS
AND TO HELP OUR DECARBONIZE OUR
ENERGY SOURCES- WE DO A BY A
SUPPORTER TODAY CATHERINE ROTOR
SUTTER WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND GREG RIDDLER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA EFFICIENCY
DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL AND I
KEPT IT REALLY SHORT FOR YOU
ALSO IF YOU ASK A LOT OF
QUESTIONS YOU'RE GONNA UNDO ALL
OF THAT. BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
THEM ANYWAY SO WILL WILL- REMIND
YOUR- WITNESSES IT YOU DO HAVE
A- THE- PERSON SECOND WITH A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION ARE THEY
HERE TO SPEAK. I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE ON THE PHONE THEY MAKE A
ON THE TELEVISION MODERATOR. ALL
WITNESSES FOR A DIGITAL RECORDS
THAT ARE ON THE PHONE. AND CLICK
WHAT WAS ON THE PHONE AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE BEGIN. THANK
YOU GARCIA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- AGAIN THIS IS CAITLYN
BROKERS BETTER SENIOR MANAGER
CLIMATE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND THEN HERE IN
FAVOR OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN BILL AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY SEVEN- THE CREATION OF
THIS INCENTIVE PROGRAM WILL HELP
UNLOCK DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES FOR CUSTOMERS THIS
INCLUDES TECHNOLOGIES TO ENABLE
DEMAND MANAGEMENT SMALL SCALE
RENEWABLE GENERATION ENERGY
STORAGE SMART CHARGING OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. CLEAN BACKUP
POWER IN EVEN THE MOBILE POWER
STATION IN THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT ME- THE INCUMBENT
OPERATES IN HE BILL WILL
ACCELERATE THE STATE CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS AND THEIR ADOPTION
WILL ALSO HELP ENSURE
RELIABILITY RESILIENCE AND
EQUITY- AS YOU'RE ALL AWARE
AGENCIES INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA CUTIE RECENTLY
EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT OVER
RELYING ON CUSTOMER RATE THE FUN
NEW CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAM. AND
THIS BILL DOES NOT UTILIZE
REPAIR FUNDS AND WILL NOT IMPACT. COSTA RICA ENERGY BILL. I DO
WISH THAT- ZERO BE A- ESPECIALLY
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY BE AND
EMERGING CATEGORY IF YOU'RE
ENERGY READ- WITH THE STREET
COULD. OF THE ADVANCED ADVANCE
CLEAN TRUCKS INTENDING
CONSIDERATION OF THE BAND
QUICKLY CRAWLED. ON CALIFORNIA'S
REALLY PRIMED TO DECARBONISE THE
MAJOR PORTION OF OUR ECONOMY AND
USING FUNDS FROM THIS PROGRAM TO
HELP ON LOCK MARC CHARGING OF
THESE VEHICLES AND BY TREATING
THEM AS A DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
SOURCE. COULD BE
TRANSFORMATIONAL AND COULD HELP
FURTHER REDUCE LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS SO FOR THAT REASON. I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT SUBWAY
PLEASE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
GARCIA MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS GREG WITH CLEAR AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA FISHING SCENE
DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL
COUNCIL WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE AT THAT
STATEWIDE TRADE ASSOCIATION MORE
THAN SEVENTY NINE UTILITY
COMPANIES. THAT PROVIDE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY DEMAND RESPONSE AND
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCE
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX
SIXTY SEVEN. THE CREATION OF AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY SEVEN WILL HELP OPEN UP A
NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES.
FOR ALL CUSTOMERS. D. E. OURS
INCLUDE TECHNOLOGIES TO ENABLE
DEMAND MANAGEMENT WHICH WHEN
CALLED UPON. DURING THE AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY BLACKOUTS SAVE
MORE THAN A THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
OF POWER BURNING FURTHER
DISASTER. CURRENTLY UPFRONT
PURCHASING COSTS AND COMPLICATED
STATE APPLICATION PROCESSES CAN
BE SIGNIFICANT DETERRENTS TO
CUSTOMER ADOPTION AND GREAT
BENEFITS. THIS BILL WILL HELP
ENABLE WIDER SUBSCRIPTION OF
THESE RESOURCES BY CREATING AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM ALLOWING
RETAIL PROVIDERS TO APPLY FOR
FUNDING ON BEHALF OF CUSTOMERS.
THIS COULD RESULT IN THE RIGHT
INCENTIVES TO EXPAND THE STATE'S
CAPABILITIES TO STABILIZE THE
GRID OVER ROLLING BLACKOUTS AND
HELD A SUNBLOCK THE LAST AND
MOST DIFFICULT PHASE OF MEETING
OUR STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY GOALS.
TO CLEAN FLEXIBLE POWER FOR
THESE REASONS I ENCOURAGE YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY.
INDIVIDUALS IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO. SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. OKAY HOW ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE MISTER MODERATOR-
AND- SUPPORT. YOU TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN
USING YOUR PHONE THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE
THREE FORTY. THANK YOU MR CARE
NUMBERS THAT WERE LARGER WITH
THE CLIMATE CENTER IN SUPPORT.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE THREE FIFTEEN. ALL WITH ABOUT HALF OF COLUSA
IN SUPPORT. THAT WOULD ALIGN
WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THAT'S LINE TWO HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR TO NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
TURN MEMBER MADELINE COOPER FROM
YELTSIN MARC BERMAN BEHALF OF
ENERGY AND WE'RE PLEASED THAT
THE POOR AB TWO SIX SIX SEVEN
THANK YOU. NO FURTHER LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU I'M GONNA ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE THE ROOM WHICH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OKAY SEE NO
ONE COME FORWARD ANYONE ON THE
PHONE CALLS. GET TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. THERE ARE NO LINES
WAITING QUEUE AT THIS TIME IF
YOU THERE IS A MOTION AND
SECOND. I'LL BRING IT BACK TO
DISS AREN'T ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. CONCERNS OR COMPLAINTS
WILL TAKE IT BACK TO THE AUTHOR
I APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU THE
MOTION IS TO PASS IT. NATURAL
RESOURCES SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL EDUARDO GARCIA o
EDUARDO GARCIA I PATTERSON.
BRIAN BRIAN I CARILLO. GEN CHEN
NOT VOTING CUNNINGHAM. CRISTINA
GARCIA HOLDEN. HOLDEN II MAYES
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI AYE MEDINA
MEDINA AYE REYES. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE TING TING I RIVAS
RIVAS I. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT ITEM EIGHT ZERO WE'LL KEEP
THAT OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
ADD ON THIS IS OUR FINAL ITEM
ITEM SIX A. B. TWENTY SIXTY ONE
WAS PAYING. A YOU DO HAVE A- TO
PASS. AS AMENDED RECOMMENDATION
. YOU MAY BEGIN THANK YOU WITH A
SURE THING LET ME JUST THANK YOU
AND THE COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THE BILL I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE REQUIRES
CHARGING COMPANIES TO PROVIDE
DATA TO THE STATE ON THE
RELIABILITY OF THEIR CHARGER
SHOULD THE USE PUBLIC FUNDS TO
DEPLOY THEM INCLUDING REPAIR
FUNDING. THANK YOU THE BILL
TAFFY ENERGY COMMISSION WITH
USING THIS DATA TO REGULARLY
ASSESS OVERALL RELIABILITY. A
PUBLICLY FUNDED CHARGING
STATIONS INCLUDING ASSESSING IF
THERE ARE ANY DISPARITIES IN
ASSESSING. RELIABLE CHARGE
OFFICIALS BETWEEN COMMUNITIES- I
HAVE- TWO WITNESSES. ONE FROM
FLOW AND ONE FROM CHARTER HELP.
WITHOUT RESPECT FOR HIS FRIEND
BUT YOU DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON. THE TABLE HERE PLEASE
. GOOD AFTERNOON MR SHARE
MEMBERS COR BOLTS ON BEHALF OF
FLOW WE ARE EVEY CHARGING
STATION PROVIDER AND I'VE BEEN
IN BUSINESS. FOR OVER TEN YEARS
SELLING OVER AND HAVE SOLD OVER
SIXTY THOUSAND CHARGING STATIONS
TO DATE NORTH AMERICA. I WOULD
YOU SAY. THIS DATA IS CRITICAL
TO UNDERSTANDING HOW EEVEE
CHARGER RELIABILITY IS IMPACTING
EVEY ADOPTION IN THE STATE SO
CAN HELP US. REACH OUR GOALS IF
WE UNDERSTAND THAT AND ADDRESS
ANY ISSUES RELATED TO STATION
RELIABILITY AND COMPANIES LIKE
US WE ALREADY HAVE THE DATA WE
ALREADY RECORDED WE CAN PROVIDE
WE THINK IT'S A FAIR REQUEST FOR
USING PUBLIC FUNDS. TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THE NEXT WITNESS
I THINK IS ON THE ON THE LINE. A
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. SO IT'S EIGHT ON BEHALF
OF CHARTER HEALTH AND ALSO- IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIXTY ONE CHARGER HEALTH IS A
TECHNOLOGY COMPANY THAT ENABLES
ON DEMAND DIAGNOSTIC MAINTENANCE
AND REPAIR OF ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING STATION. WILD BILL THE
OUTLOOK WORK FORCES AND ENABLING
ECONOMIC MOBILITY WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU WALLOWER
I'M SORRY GO AHEAD I'M SORRY
WHERE A MOM'S MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESS HEADQUARTERED IN
OFFENSE AND ARE EXPANDING OUR
FOOTPRINT NATIONALLY SERVICE
THOUSANDS OF CHARGING STATIONS
BUT THE WIDE RANGE OF EQUIPMENT
AND COMPLEXITIES EXISTING IN THE
MARKET TODAY WE PARTNER WITH A
SOFTWARE COMPANY THAT
MANUFACTURES TO SUPPORT THE DATA
COLLECTION LAW R. ECSC
TECHNICIANS ARE ON SITE
REPAIRING THE CHARGING STATION
WHICH HELPS COMPANIES IMPROVE
THE PERFORMANCE AND PRODUCT. WE
HAVE FOUND IN OUR WORK. BUDGET
CLEARLY AND- THAT PUBLIC A
THIRTY OF CHARGING A BROKEN AT
ANY TIME. YOU KNOW GIVEN THAT.
GOLD DEPLOYMENT BUCKLE OKAY
FIFTY THOUSAND CHARGING STATE.
BY TWENTY FIVE AND ONE POINT
FIVE. IS THERE A ONE POINT TWO
MILLION TWENTY FIVE. THIS AMOUNT
OF OPERABILITY. ON THE WHETHER.
WE HAVE SHOWN THE PROGRESS
ARGUED GOALS. EARLY UNDERMINES
OUR ABILITY TO INCREASE THE
ADOPTION. HE ALSO WANT TO ENSURE
THAT LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES ARE
EXPERIENCING BROKEN. ARE NOT
EXPERIENCING BROKEN. PUBLIC
CHARTERS MORE OFTEN FOR LONGER
PERIODS OF TIME. MORE I
COMMUNITIES. OTHERWISE IT'LL
YOUR AN APPLE. AND THE EXTENT OF
THE- AB WORK IN FACT IF YOU HAVE
NO WAY OF KNOWING. WE HAVE NO
WAY OF KNOWING THAT WE COULD NOT
COLLECT THE DATA REQUIRED. CAN
YOU BADLY ON A BROADER SCALE SO
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AND BELIEVE
AB TWENTY FIFTY ONE. TAKE THE
REASONABLE APPROACH TO THIS
ISSUE FOR THIS REASON WE-
ACTUALLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND
HELP YOU THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA
ASK- THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK-
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. PLEASE COME FORWARD STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION. A
POSITION. TESTING GOOD EVENING
TERM TO GARCIA SB MEMBERS KIND
OF WORKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS AS WELL AS
THE COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
UTILITY EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO SIX ZERO ONE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU ASKING IF
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM. IS
WISHING TO SPEAK. FAVOR AGAINST
THAT SCENE NO ONE WAS THE
MODERATOR OF. THERE ARE- ANYONE
ON THE LINES WHICH IS BIGGER
FAVOR AGAINST. AB TWENTY SIX ONE
Q. IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
EITHER FAVOR OR AGAINST THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO. FOR
THE FIRST TIME I AM THREE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
BEEN SUPPORT LARGER WITH QUITE A
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. YEAH 299% HI THIS IS
SANTIAGO RODRIGUEZ OF
CALIFORNIANS I'M INTROVERTED
CALLING AT THE PORT. THANK YOU
YEAH BLAMES. THREE FORTY FOUR.
GOOD EVENING NATALIE MAC FROM
THE APPLE VALLEY CLEAN AIR NOW
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE TWENTY TWO. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS CREAM
GREASY ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IT IS
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
AUTHORS ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT WHICH ADDRESSES OUR
CONCERNS- BASED ON THAT
UNDERSTANDING C. R. IS
WITHDRAWING ITS OPPOSITION IS
NOW NEUTRAL ON THE MEASURE WE
WISH TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIANG ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES- THE
SPONSORS AS WELL AS COMEDIAN
COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR WORKING
WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATED AND WE
ARE NOW NEUTRAL THE MEASURE WE
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
AMENDMENT TO PRINT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. I SAW. WITH THAT
THERE ARE NO FOR THE LINES IN Q.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- I GUESS WE
HAVE SOMEONE. WALKED IN LATE.
CLUB PLEDGES MISTER CHAIRMAN
SCOTT WHICH IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES. INSTANCES ASIAN
ELECTRICAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT
TO- DYTISCIDAE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. THERE'S A MOTION A
SECOND- THAT THAT VOTE WOULD
LIKE CLOSE JUST AUTHOR OF A
THANK YOU THANK YOU HAVE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. IT IS A
DO PASSAGE- AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA HI
EDUARDO GARCIA I PATTERSON.
BRYANT BRIAN I CARILLO. CHEN
CHEN AYE CUNNINGHAM ESTELA
GARCIA HOLDEN HOLDEN I. MAYES
RCG MURATSUCHI AYE MEDINA MEDINA
AYE REYES. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
THINK THING I RIVAS RIVAS I.
NINE ZERO OKAY WE'RE GONNA LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IN THE ITEMS THAT- ARE
YET TO BE VOTED ON- WE'RE GONNA
ASK- CHARGES OF PLEASE CALL
THOSE ABSENT MEMBERS WERE GONNA
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR. FIVE MINUTES. AND I WANT TO THANK OUR- A
BACKUP TEAM THAT WAS HERE TO-
COVER IDENTITIES COMMITTEE.
NUMBER THREE THREE. ZERO THE
TEAM. THE TEAM WE ARE CURRENTLY
WATCHING A- HBO I DON'T KNOW
LIKE NOT HAVE A- I GOT LUCKY.
YEAH I WAS NOT EIGHTEEN PP IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD YEAH. YEAH ALL
THE WE WILL. ACCORDING THIS IS
FOR SOMEONE ELSE. RIGHT YEAH
OKAY YEAH I.
RIGHT YEAH. MR I WOULD NEVER
KNOW YEAH ABOUT FIVE MINUTES
OKAY I MEAN I GET IT. I FORGOT
ABOUT. YEAH YEAH NUMBER. YEAH WE
GOT. ONE WE'RE GONNA CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS- WE'RE GONNA
START AT THE TOP OF THE AGENDA
AND SECRETARY. I DON'T ONE AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SIX CUNNINGHAM
CRISTINA GARCIA MAYES SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I THINK OUR TEAM I.
ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN OKAY WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR TWO MORE
MINUTES. I AM TOO AB. TWENTY SIX
SIXTY SEVEN. PATTERSON YOU
CUNNINGHAM CREEK CRISTINA GARCIA
MAYES YES HI REYES AYE NINE
ZERO. BUT GALLAGHER. CONSENT
CALENDAR WE ALREADY DID WE JUST
AT THE CALENDAR OKAY. I HAVE A
FOUR. I DON'T FOR AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY THREE. CUNNINGHAM CRISTINA
GARCIA MAYES REYES REYES AYE
ELEVEN ZERO. IDM SIX AB TWENTY
SIXTY ONE PATTERSON CARILLO
CUNNINGHAM CRISTINA GARCIA MAYES
RAFTS REYES I'D TEN ZERO. APART
ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN CUNNINGHAM CRISTINA GARCIA
MAYES SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I TEEN
TEEN I TWELVE ZERO. AND ITEM
EIGHT AB TWENTY SIX NINETY SIX
CUNNINGHAM CRISTINA GARCIA MAYES
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I TING TING I. ELEVEN ZERO. IF YOU TO ALL OF
. WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THREE MORE MINUTES FOR
THE OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON YOUR. I FEEL FOR THEM. IT TAKES
TWENTY FIVE MINUTES TO GET. I'M
GIVING YOU A HARD. DOES THANK
YOU. EARLIER THIS TO FIGURE BUT
I STILL MY TRUCK AND I THE
DEFENSE AND REALIZE I KNOW ALL
THE WAY AROUND AND- IT'S NOT AS
SIMPLE TO USE. YEAH. YOU IN YOUR
- BUT. THANK YOU FOR THE CUSHION
A DIFFICULT THING YEAH. YOU KNOW
I STARTED TALKING SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN FIVE AND SEVEN MODEL
BILLION PEOPLE AND. YEAH YOU
KNOW. YEAH I THINK GOT YEAH
THANK YOU. OKAY YEAH MAKING FUN
OF WAS A GOOD PHONE IT TAKES A
LITTLE. I THINK THEY'RE BOTH.
ALL RIGHT GREAT I'M NOT RIGHT.
IT'S THE OTHER WAY. WE'RE GOING
TO WORK IN THE FINANCE OFFICE
YEAH PEOPLE OF. THIS IS A. OKAY
SO- GET. OKAY NOW. CORRECTLY
WE'VE- SO. EIGHT THAT WOULD BE
GREAT EIGHT. OKAY YEAH THE
PEOPLE. I LOVE YOU FOR THAT YEAH
YEAH HELLO TO THEIR PLACE THEIR
I THINK THAT SIMPLIFIED
EVERYTHING WE HAVE A RIGHT. THAT
HELLO THIS IS THE START WELL
YEAH. IF YOU HAVE LIKE WITH.
OKAY RIGHT. YEAH JUST SUCH A
PEOPLE PERSON CALIFORNIA YEAH
CONVERSATION. WE KEEP OURSELVES. OKAY SO. SURE YOU SIDE OF THE
WORLD. RIGHT THE FUTURE WORK.
BUYERS SHOULD AND- WE- WILL HAVE
THREE MINUTES YEAH IT WOULD
CRISTINA STUFF OKAY YEAH THAT'S
RIGHT. PEOPLE SHOULD. AND YEAH.
ABOUT.
QUALITATIVELY SEATING CRISTINA
RUN- YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH. HELLO
COMMITTEE ON. THEY WERE VERY
WARM OPEN. LIKE THIS WE USED TO
BE A WRITER. SO LONG. THAT'S
RIGHT I MEAN I KNOW YOU LIKE
PHILADELPHIA PA. FOR THE PAST
SEVEN OKAY.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP THE-
ROLE FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON. AB
FOR THE CONSECUTIVE- HI
CUNNINGHAM CREEK CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I MAYES. TWELVE
ZERO FOR. ITEM TO TWENTY AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SEVEN. CARILLO
OUR SORRY PATTERSON CARILLO
CUNNINGHAM CRISTINA GARCIA. AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SEVEN FREE
FRIEDMAN. I CRISTINA GARCIA I
MAYES THAT'S TEN ZERO THE- ITEM
FOR AB TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE
CARILLO. CUNNINGHAM CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA I MAYES
TWELVE ZERO. IDM SIX AB TWENTY
SIXTY WANTING PATTERSON CARILLO
CUNNINGHAM CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I MAYES. ELEVEN
ZERO. IDM SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN EDUARDO GARCIA
CUNNINGHAM CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I MAYES AS
THIRTEEN ZERO. AND LAST ONE ITEM
EIGHT AB TWENTY SIX NINETY SIX
EDUARDO GARCIA. CUNNINGHAM
CRISTINA GARCIA HI CRISTINA
GARCIA I MAYES THAT'S TWELVE
THERE ALL RIGHT AT THIS TIME WE
WILL ADJOURN THE- REGULAR
MEETING OF THE TWO THOUSAND MG
COMMITTEE THANK YOU EVERYONE.